SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE WILL
COME TO ORDER. I'M GOING TO DO
TELL OUR PROCESS TODAY. IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTEC THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES
WE MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS IN AND HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES. IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THESE ORDERS THE SENATORS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARING TODAY IN THE
CAPITAL WITH. OF SOME MEMBERS-
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE REMOTELY BUT
ALL OF THE SENATORS ON THE SUB
COMMITTEE WILL BE HERE- IN THE
HEARING ROOM. ARE THOSE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR A
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN- A LIMITING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. LASTED
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU'RE USED TO
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE. PLEASE
SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING R. I. T. PERSONNEL WILL
PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE WHEN YOU
WERE DONE. ONCE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK PLEASE MAKE SURE THAT YOU
CAN BE SEEN ON THE SCREEN STATE
YOUR NAME AND THEN YOU'RE READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED PUBLIC MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE HEARING ROOM TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING. REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT WHICH WE WILL DO AFTER
WE HEAR ALL THE INDIVIDUAL
ISSUES. THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
AND IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN IT IS I SEE IT AND- I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. IT'LL BE.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX
EIGHT ONE SIX THREE. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE SIX
THREE AND THE ACCESS CODE WILL
BE SEVEN THREE SIX TWO EIGHT
THREE THREE THAT SEVEN THREE SIX
TWO EIGHT THREE THREE. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES DIM WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE AND WE'RE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED
TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL BE
PROMPTED BY MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE ZERO. PRESS THIS ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER THIS CAN BE A SHORT WHITE
ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LONG
NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE
FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR
LINE NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU
WILL BE ON MUTED AND YOU ARE NOW
READY TO ADDRESS TO COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US
TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING TEST
IS CUSTOMARY. THAN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHOSE DISRUPTIVE MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
HEARING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. IN TODAY'S
HEARING. WHICH IS THE FIFTH OF
TEN BUDGET HEARINGS WE OF THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE AND IN FIVE WEEKS
AND WE WILL HAVE THE SIX
TOMORROW IN TODAY'S HEARING WE
WILL REVIEW THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS AROUND GREEN SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION NUTRITION MULTI
LINGUAL LIBRARIES FACILITIES AND
A CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECT. SO
WITH NO FURTHER ADO. WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO ISSUE NUMBER ONE WHICH
IS SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION AND
HERE WITH US OUR WINNER GRANT
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
CAN COUPON FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE ONE MORALIS.
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
AND WE'RE GOING TO TAKE THE
PANELISTS IN THAT ORDER AND
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH WIENER
GRANT FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION NO WELCOME TO THE SUB
COMMITTEE. I THANK YOU LEANING
GREAT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE GOOD
MORNING AND THANK YOU TRAILER
AND SENATORS- THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION ONE TIME PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND. TO
SUPPORT THE SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION GRANT PROGRAM
WHICH FOCUSES ON GREENING SCHOOL
BUS FLEETS. THIS IS A GRANTS OF
AT LEAST FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS WOULD BE AVAILABLE WITH
PRIORITY FOR RETIRING OUR LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES OLDEST
INTERNAL COMBUSTION BUSES.
ELEAZAR THE HIGHEST
CONCENTRATION OF UNDUPLICATED
PUPILS AS WELL AS SMALL AND
RURAL RURAL ELEAZAR. IN KEEPING
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION'S LARGER
FOCUS ON REDUCING HARMFUL
VEHICLE EMISSIONS WITH GRANTS OF
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND AND ELLIE
EIGHT WILL BE ABLE TO ACQUIRE
ELECTRIC SCHOOL BUS PURCHASE AND
CONSTRUCT THE BUSES CHARGING
STATION AND ALSO SUPPORT OTHER
LOCAL. SCHOOL BUS TRANSPORTATION
NEEDS. THESE INVESTMENTS WILL
RESULT IN ONGOING SAVINGS TO
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS THAT CAN
BE USED TO SUPPORT OTHER ASPECTS
OF AN ALLEY A STUDENT TRANSPORT
. THIS CONCLUDES MY PRESSURE
REMARKS- BUT I'M APPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL DO
THE QUESTIONS AFTER ALL THREE
PANELISTS HAVE PRESENTED WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS CAN
COMBINE WITH THE ANALYST OFFICE
SOME BRIEF BACKGROUND HERE. A
SCHOOL DISTRICTS CURRENTLY OWN
ABOUT SIXTEEN THOUSAND SCHOOL
BUSES NEARLY TWO THIRDS OF THOSE
BUSES ARE DIESEL. IN MANY OF
THOSE DIESEL BUSES ARE OLDER
MODELS THAT WERE MANUFACTURED
UNDER LESS STRINGENT EMISSION
STANDARDS THAN THOSE EXISTING
TODAY. OTHER MAJOR DISTRICTS
FLEETS GENERALLY OPERATE ON A
ALTERNATIVE FUELS MAINLY
COPRESSED NATURAL GAS OR
PROPANE. ELECTRIC BUSES ARE THE
NEWEST OPTION DISTRICTS BEYOND
BUYING ABOUT FIVE YEARS AGO AND
CURRENTLY OWNS SEVERAL HUNDRED
STATEWIDE. ELECTRIC BUSES HAVE
SNORKEL ADVANTAGES THAT THEY DO
NOT PRODUCE ANY TAILPIPE
EMISSIONS HONEYMOON HELPS. IT
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS GREENHOUSE.
GAS AND TO BE TO OPERATE BECAUSE
THEY LIKE. TO TRY TO BE JUST
LAST SIX AND YOU FUEL. AT THE
MAIN LIMIT IS RANGE NOT MANY
ELECTED BY. HAVE A MAX RANGE
TODAY A HUNDRED AND TWENTY AND A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILES. IN THAT
RANGE CAN OFTEN BE LASSEN
STRENUOUS OPERATING CONDITIONS
LIKE MOUNTAINOUS TERRAIN ARE HOT
AND COLD WEATHER. AND THE UP
FRONT COST AN ELECTRIC BUS ALSO
ARE ABOUT TWICE AS MUCH AS THE
UP FRONT COST OF THE DIESEL BUS
. I THINK THE- GIVE YOU OVERVIEW
OF THE PROPOSAL. I WOULD POINT
OUT THAT IT IS ON TOP OF A LARGE
FEDERAL PROGRAM CREATED LAST
NOVEMBER. FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS STATE PROGRAM
CREATED IN THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO BUDGET. AND A COUPLE OF
SMALLER STATE PROGRAMS. THAT WE
THINK THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
ADVANCED A PROMISING IDEA. USING
ONE TIME FUNDS TO PURCHASE
ELECTRIC BUSES COULD PROVIDE
EMISSION BENEFITS THAT WOULD
LAST FOR MANY YEARS. AND IT
WOULD GIVE DISTRICTS SOME COST
RELEASE- BOTH RELATED TO THE
COST OF REPLACING OLDER BUSES.
AND OVER A LONGER PERIOD THE
COST OF PURCHASING FUEL. I WOULD
RECOMMEND YOU ADOPT THE PROPOSAL
I WAS A COUPLE OF MODIFICATIONS.
THE FIRST WOULD BE TO MAKE SPEED
MY MAIN PRIORITY OF THE PROGRAM-
THE REPLACEMENT OF OLDER BUSES.
SO WHERE IS THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES THE AGE OF THE BUSES
BEING REPLACED AS ONE FACTOR.
YOU RECKON MAKING IT THE MAIN
FACTOR. AND THAT'S BECAUSE OLDER
BUSES EMIT MORE POLLUTION
REPLACING THEM FIRST BUT
MAXIMIZE THE POTENTIAL. AIR
QUALITY IMPROVEMENTS. WE ARE
ALLOWING FOR OTHER TYPES OF. AND
BUS ARE NOT. THIS IS AN ISSUE
PRIMARY AFFECTS DISTRICTS WITH
LONGER. ROUTE AND IN THOSE
DISTRICTS REPLACING OLDER NOT
YOU NOT LIKE BUSQUETS ACHIEVE
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTIONS IN
POLLUTION. THAT WE RECOMMEND
ELIMINATING THE QUESTION OF THE
GRANTS THAT WOULD PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR OTHER TRANSPORTATION%
COSTS. US ABOUT 10% OF THE
PROPOSAL. I THAT QUESTION OF THE
GRANT TO BUY DOES NOT SEEM
CLEARLY CONNECTED WITH
UNDERLYING COSTS OF PURCHASING
LIKE TO SCHOOL BUSES WERE
RUNNING A SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM. WE ALSO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS THAT IT COULD
DISCOURAGE DISTRICTS REPLYING
FOR BUS REPLACEMENT FUNDING FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OR OTHER
STATE PROGRAMS. SOME OF THOSE
OTHER PROGRAMS DO NOT PROVIDE
THAT ADDITIONAL ON. I WOULD
RECKON STARTING OF THE SMALLER
INITIAL TO THE POINT. AND
ALLOCATE FUNDING SEVERAL. WHICH
WOULD GIVE THE LEGISLATURE
OPPORTUNITY YOU TO ADJUST THE
PROGRAM IN THE FUTURE BASED ON
INTEREST IN THE PROGRESS OF THE
STATE NEXT TOWARDS A PLACING.
THE OLDER BUSES SO FOR EXAMPLE
ONE OPTION COULD BE TO START
WITH AN INITIAL ALLOCATION OF
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION. THAT WOULD
BE ENOUGH TO REPLACE MORE THAN A
THOUSAND SCHOOL BUSES AND THEN
PLAN FOR SUBSEQUENT INSTALLMENTS
OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS. IF YOU
DO START WITH THE FULL ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION THAT THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES. WE'D RECOMMEND
ALLOWING SOME OF THAT FUNDING TO
BE USED FOR EXPANDING DISTRICT
FLEETS NOT JUST A PLACING
DISTINCT BUSES. AND THAT
APPROACH WOULD ENSURE THAT THE
STATE CAN ALLOCATE THE FULL
AMOUNT INTERESTED INTERESTED
DISTRICTS. WELL WOULD SEE
CONCERT WHICH DAY AGENCY AS BEST
POSITIONED TO ADMINISTER THE
PROGRAM. THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES
IT TO THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION WE THINK THEY ARE
CAPABLE OF MANAGING THE PROGRAM
THEY BY MANY TYPES OF
COMPETITIVE GRANTS AND THEY
PREVIOUSLY MANAGED A SMALL BUS
REPLACEMENT PROGRAM FOR SMALL
DISTRICTS. ON THE OTHER HAND THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
ALREADY OVERSEES THE BUS
REPLACEMENT PROGRAM CREATED IN
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET. AND A
DIVIDING TO SIMILAR PROGRAMS
ACROSS THE TWO AGENCIES LIKE WE
WOULD REQUIRE I BOTH HAVE AN
EDUCATION AND THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD TO ENGAGE IN
SOME SIGNIFICANT COORDINATION
SINCE MANY DISTRICTS LIKE THAT
WOULD APPLY FOR BOTH. BOTH BOTH
GRANT PARK. I THIS NEW APPROACH
TO THE AREAS BOARD MIGHT AVOID
OF THAT AND FORTH YES ONE
RESPONDING ELKE PROCESS. AND
THAT CONCLUDES OUR COMMON. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MOVE TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. WHY MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AGAIN
MY NAME IS JUANITA ELLIS I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE SCHOOL
FACILITIES AND TRANSPORTATION
SERVICES DIVISION ATTY IT'S A
PLEASURE TO BE HERE WITH YOU
TODAY. FIRST WE DO WANT TO THANK
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR PROPOSING
SUCH A SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN
THE AREA SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION
WE KNOW THAT MANY STUDENTS RELY
ON A SCHOOL BUS TO BE ABLE TO
GET TO SCHOOL EACH DAY. IN FACT
IT IS ESTIMATED THAT
APPROXIMATELY ONE MILLION
STUDENTS AND TRANSPORTED DAILY.
TRANSFERS TO ATTEND SCHOOL BUS
HAS PROVEN NOT TO BE NOT ONLY
THE SAFEST WAYTO GET TO SCHOOL.
BUT IT ALSO HELPS REMOVE OTHER
CARS FROM THE ROAD. AS ONE
SCHOOL BUS CAN CARRY THE
EQUIVALENT ABOUT THIRTY SIX
CARS. WE ALSO AGREE THE OLDER
SCHOOL BUSES NEED TO BE REPLACED
WITH NEWER TECHNOLOGY. THAT WILL
NOT ONLY HELP CALIFORNIA ACHIEVE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS. BUT
THEY WILL ALSO LOWER THE
OPERATIONAL COST FOR OUR DAILY
AS- AND NOT JUST MUCH MORE SHORT
TERM BUT FOR MANY YEARS TO COME
. TO THAT END WE WE'RE THRILLED
THE MINISTRATIONS PROPOSING TO
INVEST ONE POINT FIVE BILLION.
FOR THE CREATION OF THE SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION GRANT PROGRAM. TO
REPLACE OLDER BUSES IN SOME OF
THE NEEDIEST AREAS OF THE STATE.
IT IS ESTIMATED THAT THE FUNDING
WILL REPLACE APPROXIMATELY THREE
THOUSAND OLDER BUSES. SO THE
IMPACT THAT THIS INVESTMENT WILL
HAVE ON OUR SCHOOLS. OUR
COMMUNITIES AND THE ENVIRONMENT
IN GENERAL IS QUITE CLEAR. OF
COURSE ADMINISTERING SUCH A
LARGE AMOUNT OF FUNDING THROUGH
A COMPETITIVE GRANT PROCESS
WOULD REQUIRE DEDICATED
RESOURCES TO ENSURE THE
PROGRAM'S SUCCESS. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ADMINISTRATION FUNDS
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU THANK YOU
OUR OUR APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
QUESTIONS AND I'M GOING TO
BEGIN. N. LET ME ASK THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. OF THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S JUST
POINTED OUT THAT THIS WOULD
CREATE TO GRANT PROGRAMS INTO
DEPARTMENTS THAT NEED TO BE
COORDINATED AND- FOR- MIGHT BE
CONFUSING AND- WHY. OF DID YOU
CHOOSE TO HAVE THESE TWO
PROGRAMS- IT DID NOT PUT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION OF. OF THIS NEW
PROGRAM WITH CARB THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD. I THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION LEAK IN A GRANT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I'M STILL
ALTHOUGH CARDS FUNDING OF
ELECTRIC BUSES THAT'S PROVIDE
INCENTIVE. GRANT SUPPORT I
LIAISE TO PURCHASE AN ELECTRIC
SCHOOL BUS THAT THOSE INCENTIVES
OUT SURE IS ONLY PARTIALLY COVER
THE COST OF AN ELECTRIC BUS IN
BED POGRAM WE'RE PROPOSING
WOULD BE PROPOSING TO OUR ALL
RIGHT REPLACE A DIESEL BUSES
WITH ELECTRIC BUS AT A MINIMUM
IT WOULD ALSO PROVIDE.
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO ACQUIRE
THE CHARGING STATION
INFRASTRUCTURE- AND WE'RE
CERTAINLY COORDINATING OUR
EFFORTS WITH BOTH CARD AND THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION IN
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THIS PROGRAM
SO WE CAN BETTER ALIGN OUR
EFFORTS AND LIKE ON MY. A
COLLEAGUE AT THE ALLEY-
MENTIONED- THAT CITY HAS HIS
STORY USE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND ON SCHOOL
BUSES- LIKE THE FORMER SMALL
SCHOOL DISTRICT. TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM THEN THAT RAN FOR MANY
YEARS FROM NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX I
BELIEVE TWENTY TWELVE. THAT WAS
THEN ABSORBED INTO THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA- I THINK
THAT WAS ALSO MENTIONED IN THE
REPORT ON PAGE SEVEN. HOME TO
SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM
JUST CURRENTLY AN ADD ON WITHIN
THE LC FIVE ALSO ALLOWS. FOR THE
PURCHASE OF A SCHOOL BUS THAT
SPECIFICALLY AUTHORIZES BASSES
AS THE PAYMENT OF MONIES BY A
SCHOOL DISTRICT OR COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS- FOR
THE REPLACEMENT OUR ACQUISITION
OF SCHOOL BUSES. I'M SO
CURRENTLY THERE THERE'S ALREADY
AN ABILITY FOR LEDS TO USE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND TO PURCHASE A SCHOOL BUS
AND WE ARE. SUPPORTING WE'RE
TRYING TO ACCELERATE THIS EFFORT
TO BRING SCHOOL BUS FLEETS.
AROUND THE STATE. OUR LET ME MAY
A CALM NOW ON THE RATHER THAN-
AT THE END OF THIS. SECTION AND
I THINK FREQUENTLY ONCE PRO
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS OR STAB
WISHED. ARE YOU GO AND MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC SAY WHY WAS THIS
DIVIDED WHAT WHAT PRICES IN TWO
DIFFERENT AGENCIES AND- YOU HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY USUALLY. FOR ONE
AGENCY TO SAY. R. THIS IS REALLY
GOOD FOR THE PARTIAL REPLACEMENT
THAT'S WHAT YOU QUALIFY FOR
SHOULD GO HERE FOR ALL WE COULD
DO THE FULL BOAT IF YOU PART WE
CAN FUND THE WHOLE THING TO THE
CHARGING STATION DO THE OTHER
THINGS THAT YOU MENTIONED AND- I
WOULD JUST ASK THAT BETWEEN NOW
AND THE MAY REVISE YOU GIVE REAL
CONSIDERATION TO WHETHER OR NOT
THEY SHOULD BE CONSOLIDATED IN
ONE AGENCY. BECAUSE THAT MAKES A
LOT OF SAID SAID N. I JUST KNOW
THAT. IF YOU LOOK AT ALL THESE
OTHER THINGS I MEAN IF YOU LOOK
AT THE CLEAN WATER PROGRAM WHERE
IT WAS IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH AND NOT COORDINATED. IN
MANY NOT GETTING OUT THE DOOR
AND NOT COORDINATING- WITH THE
WATER BOARD AND IF IN THE- ARM.
IN THE END ID IT HAD TO BE MOVED
TO THE WATER BOARDS SO THAT THAT
KIND OF COORDINATION HAPPENED
FORTY AND I THINK THE SAME THING
IS HAPPENING HERE AND WE HAVE A
CHANCE TO GET A HOLD OF IT
BEFORE WE EVEN START. SAW I JUST
HOPE OVER THE NEXT FEW MONTHS
YOU WOULD GIVE CONSIDERATION TO
THAT. AND MY SECOND QUESTION-
THE FINANCE PERSON JUST
ADDRESSED WHICH IS I WAS GONNA
ASK IF THIS IS APPROPRIATE
WITHIN PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
OR WHETHER IT'S BETTER OUTSIDE
BECAUSE WE HAVE RECEIVED SOME
CRITICISM. OF FROM FROM
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS THAT
WE'VE THAT PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT SHOULD BEFOCUSED ON
INSTRUCTION IN AND THIS IS. IS
NOT THAT SO- WE JUST HEARD THE
OPINION OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE LET ME ASK DELAY- IF YOU
HAVE ANYTHING. YOU WOULD LIKE TO
ADD ON THAT SUBJECT. YEAH WE
DON'T ANY I READ THAT THIS COULD
USE PROPER. NINETY EIGHT FIND
THIS PROGRAM. AT LEAST FUNDED ON
THIS TRAFFIC NUMBER A PLACE
PROGRAM AND- I NEED AN- AND
THIS. PROPOSAL SEEMS LIKELY
COOLEY PROVIDED BENEFIT TO THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND STUDENTS.
BOTH IN THE FORM OF HELPING THEM
RUN TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS THAT
THEY FIND BENEFICIAL. AS WELL AS
THE POTENTIAL FOR COST SAVINGS
IN THE NEXT COUPLE YEARS. SO YOU
KNOW I THINK THEY COULD BE
DEPENDING ON THE OVERALL
CONSIDERING YOUR OVERALL BUDGET
PACKAGE ON THE- THINGS YOU WANT
TO DO WITHIN THE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT AND I'M PROBABLY
JUST NINETY EIGHT BUDGET. YOU
CAN THINK ABOUT WHICH FUNDS TO
USE BUT- WE WOULDN'T HAVE ANY IN
SORT OF. CONSTITUTIONAL
PROPOSITION NINETY CONCERNS
ABOUT FUNDING THIS PROGRAM
WASN'T GUARANTEE. THANK YOU. AND
I KNOW THAT FOR SOME OF STATE
CALLED THAT MAY CHRIS. IT'S
MISTER CON. ISSUE IT'S A
FUNCTIONAL. WHERE IT SHOULD BE
DONE BUT I APPRECIATE THAT BUT
APPARENTLY EVERYBODY'S HAVING
FUN TUNING UP MY NEXT QUESTION
IN THE PREVIOUS ONE SO. OUR
MODEL ASK QUESTION. MMHM
RELATES. TO HOME TO SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION IN GENERAL. AND
THE- I THINK IT WAS IN THE
TWENTY TWELVE TWENTY THIRTEEN
YEAR. OF THE LEGISLATURE
GOVERNOR FROZE LOCAL- EDUCATION
AGENCIES THE L. E. A. FUNDING OF
FOR THOSE STATE FUNDED ARE HOME
TO SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION AND
PRESIDENT PLACE SO THERE SOME
SCHOOLS TO DO IT BUT THEY DO IT
AT A LEVEL THAT IS NOW ALMOST
TEN YEARS OLD SOME SCHOOLS
DON'T. END ADDITIONALLY THE
THINGS THAT ARE PROPOSED IN THIS
BUDGET ARE REALLY ABOUT
SWITCHING OUT BUSES ABOUT
ENVIRONMENTAL PROGRAMS AND THERE
IS TALK OUT THERE AND JUSTICE
LAST WEEK WHEN WE TALKED ABOUT
THE FACT THAT THERE'S A PROPOSAL
TO SWITCH FROM EIGHTY EIGHT TO
ENROLLMENT- WE TALKED ABOUT IT
IN THE CONTEXT OF OUR HEARING SO
THAT WE'RE WE SHOULD HAVE A
DISCUSSION THERE'S NOW PROPOSAL
OUT THERE- HAPPENS TO BE BY THE
CHAIR OF THE BUDGET COMMITTEE SO
MAYBE IT'LL HAVE LEGS. OUR OWN
TO REALLY RESTORE THE MANDATE
FOR HOME TO SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION FOR ALL THAT WE
AS AND N. A. I'VE- INTERESTINGLY
ENOUGH IT'S ESTIMATED THAT IT
MIGHT COST THREE BILLION DOLLARS
WHICH IS EXACTLY THE AMOUNT. OF
THAT THE MOVING FROM A- EIGHTY
EIGHT TO AN ENROLLMENT SYSTEM
WOULD COST IF WE WERE TO HOLD
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HARMLESS MY
QUESTION IS PROBABLY FOR THE L.
A. O. GIVEN THE OF FEW DISTRICTS
THAT STILL DO WHAT ARE HOME TO
SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION AT THE
TWENTY TWELVE TO TWENTY THIRTEEN
LEVEL. AND THE PROPOSALS THAT
ARE IN THIS BUDGET FOR REPLACING
. OF BOSSES IF WE WERE TO FUND A
MANDATE FOR COMPLETE HOME TO
SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION HOW WOULD
IT OVERLAY WITH THESE BUDGET
PROPOSALS AT THE EXISTING BUDGET
EXPENDITURES HOW WOULD IT FIT
ALL TOGETHER HERE IF. IF WE WERE
THE LEGISLATURE WERE TO DECIDE
TO GO IN THAT DIRECTION. YEAH
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN WE
HAVEN'T DONE A COMPLETE- ABOUT
THE FISCAL ANALYSIS. OF THAT
BILL- S. B. THE PROPOSAL BY I
SURE SKINNER BUT JUST FOR SUNDAY
CONTEXT UNDER CURRENT LAW
DISTRICTS DECIDE WHETHER TO
PROVIDE HOME TO SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION. WHETHER THERE
ARE ANY ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA
LIKE MINIMUM WALKING DISTANCE.
OF THE MANIC SUBSTANCE
DISABILITIES WHO SOMETIMES
RECEIVE GUARANTEED
TRANSPORTATION BASED ON THEIR
INDIVIDUAL DISABILITY MISS. SO I
UNDERSTANDING OF THIS BILL IS
THAT IT WOULD REQUIRE DISTRICTS
TO PROVIDE FREE TRANSPORTATION
TO ALL STUDENTS IN KINDERGARTEN
THROUGH GRADE SIX TO LIVE MORE
THAN A HALF MILE AWAY FROM THEIR
SCIENCE SCHOOL. AND ALL STUDENTS
IN GRADES SEVEN TO TWELVE WITH
MORE THAN ONE MILE AWAY I
DISTRICTS COULD MEET THAT
REQUIREMENTS BY PROVIDING
TRANSPORTATION SCHOOL BUSES OR
BY CONTRACTING WITH MUNICIPAL.
TRANSIT AGENCIES TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICE. NEW TO BE CONTAINED ON
IF. STATE BY. THE CALIFORNIA OF
. WOULD ADMINISTER. THOSE THAT
FUNDING AS A READING AS A
REIMBURSEMENT. AND ALLOCATED TO
INDIVIDUAL DISTRICTS BASED
PRIMARILY ON THE NUMBER OF MILES
DRIVEN BY THE SCHOOL BUSES. IN
THEIR FLEETS AND I THINK THE
INTENT OF THIS PROGRAM IS THAT
THIS NEW ALLOCATION FORMULA. I
WOULD REPLACE THE EXISTING HOME
TO SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION.
ALLOTMENT TWITCHES WIDELY
REFLECTIVE OF THE TYPE SIZE OF
PROGRAMS THAT DISTRICTS WERE
RUNNING. IN THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES UNDER THE PREVIOUS
ITERATION OF THE PROGRAM. THANK
YOU A APPRECIATE THAT AND- WHILE
JUST LOOK AT THAT ASSIST. OVER
THE NEXT FOUR MONTHS OF THAT
COMPLETES MY QUESTIONS LET ME
ASK MY COLLEAGUES IF YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS ON ISSUE NUMBER
ONE. SENATOR MEANT. SO I JUST
WANT TO FOLLOW ON SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT CHAIR THERE WAS
ANYTHING EVER SO I WAS ONE- WHAT
HOW MANY SCHOOL BUSES ARE THEIR
IMPACT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA MAYBE I MISSED THAT.
IN OUR HAND OUT. AND WHO ARE YOU
DIRECT TARGET BEAT ANYONE WHO
KNOWS BUT IT PRESUMABLY IN PART
IN EDUCATION. WELL I THINK TWO
OF THEM ARE HOPING THAT THE
THIRD ONE OF CFS QUESTION RIGHT
. I MEAN I'M JUST LOOKING FOR
BALK. HI MY- YEAH YEAH THANK YOU
CENTER IN US. CURRENTLY BELIEVE
BILL LATER INDICATE THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICT PHONE ABOUT FIFTEEN.
EIGHT HUNDRED BUSES AND PRIVATE
CONTRACTORS SERVING SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ON ANOTHER NINE
THOUSAND OR SO BUSES SO- ROUGHLY
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND BUSES IN
THE STATE BUT THAT FIFTEEN
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED OWNED BY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE THE ONES
THAT ARE THE FOCUS OF THIS
PROPOSAL. AND JUST A FOLLOW UP
ON THAT THEN- MISTER CAP
ACCOUNT. LOOKS ON THE PHONE
SORRY- HOW MANY RIGHT NOW ARE
LIKE TRICK OR ZERO EMISSIONS.
RIGHT NOW ALL UNDER IS JUST OWN
SEVERAL OF THOSE- STATEWIDE- WE
DON'T HAVE A- EXACT NUMBER-
PARTLY IT'S BECAUSE MANY
DISTRICTS WE NO HAVE ORDERED-
BUSES BUT HAVEN'T RECEIVED THEM
YET SO THE NUMBER IS INCREASING
ALL OF. YOU KNOW INCREASING. AS
TIME GOES ON BUT RIGHT NOW IT'S
JUST A COUPLE HUNDRED A
STATEWIDE. NOW AND ANALYSIS THAT
WE RECEIVE FROM LA- WHICH I TAKE
ISSUE- WE- HAD IT SAID IT WAS
ABOUT A HUNDRED THOUSAND ROUGHLY
FOR THE BUS PLUS CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR EACH NEW BUS.
AND SO- I THINK IF WE DO THE
MATH IT'S AT A HUNDRED FIFTY
BUSES THAT'S WHAT WE GET FOR ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION. SO THE WAY
THE PROPOSAL IS CONSTRUCTED IS
THAT ASSUMES THAT DISTRICTS
WOULD SPEND ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND TO PURCHASE EACH BUS IN
ANOTHER FIFTY THOUSAND HONEST
CHARGING STATION. AT SEVEN FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND OKAY I THINK I
MISSED READ THIS INSTEAD OF A
HUNDRED THOUSAND I. THINK
SOMEWHERE BUT SO IT'S LIKE
LESSEN THAT SAYS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT WHAT THIRTY PLUS NO NO NO
NO YOU'RE- DROPPING ZERO IN
THERE SOMEWHERE. THREE ABOUT
THREE THOUSAND. SO ELECTRIC. I'M
SORRY YOUR OKAY. IT'S OKAY SO
THAT'LL MAKE A FEEL THAT- AND I
GUESS MY QUESTION YOU KNOW I'VE
- THE- O. C. T. A. MY OWN.
COUNTY TRANSIT. NOT SO LONG AGO.
AND THEY WERE TELLING ME THEY
WERE STILL. BETWEEN HYDROGEN
ELECTRIC IN AND KIND OF. TAKEN
SOME ELECTRIC AND SOME HYDROGEN.
THIS PROPOSAL ENVISIONS THAT
EVERYTHING WILL BE ELECTRIC. ONE
OF THE CHALLENGES THAT WAS
EXPRESSLY BY- CTAS JUST THAT THE
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE IS SO
EXPENSIVE AND SO- I DON'T KNOW
IF IT CHANGES FOR SCHOOL BUSES
SINCE YOU JUST HAVE SO FEWOF
THEM- BUT- C. T. EXPRESSED TO ME
THEY WOULD HAVE TO. INVEST
SIGNIFICANTLY MASSIVE AMOUNTS TO
TRY TO BUILD UP THE TYPE OF
ELECTRICAL CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE THEY NEED TO.
CONTINUOUSLY CHARGE THEIR BOSSES
SO THAT THEY BE REGULAR
REGULARLY A QUICK TO GO- YOU
KNOW THERE'S CHALLENGES AND
TRADEOFFS BETWEEN HYDROGEN AND
ELECTRIC BUT- I WAS WONDERING
IF. EITHER THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DEPARTMENT EDUCATION
COULD COMMENT ON THE DECISION
TO. CHOOSE A LACK FOR IT ONLY AS
OPPOSED TO ZERO EMISSIONS AS
WE'VE OFTEN DONE IN. THIS- IN
THE STATE. LENA GRANT PARK A
FINANCE SO. THE WAY THAT THE-
THE PROGRAMS CURRENTLY
STRUCTURED AND PROPOSED IN THE
TRAILER BILL. IS BUT PROVIDING
FUNDING FOR THE OUTRIGHT
REPLACING OF THE BUS THAT'S FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND AND THEN AN
ADDITIONAL FIFTY THOUSAND FOR
THE CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE
STATION. SO THAT WOULD COVER THE
COST OF CHARGING THAT THE BUS
SO- I'M NOT SURE IF MAYBE THEY
WERE CONCERNED ABOUT. THE
CURRENT INCENTIVE VOUCHER
PROGRAM THAT EXISTS WITH THE CAR
BECAUSE THAT IS THE PARTIAL
COVERING UP THE COST. THAT'S
WHAT OUT RIGHT PROVIDE FUNDING.
FOR THE FULL ELECTRIC BUS
REPLACEMENT. OKAY BUT I'M NOT
SURE THAT INTERNET QUESTION I
THINK MY QUESTIONIS WHY DID WE
CHOOSE WE MADE A DECISION TO
CHOOSE ELECTRIC AND NOT JUST
SIMPLY DO ZERO EMISSIONS AS WE
OFTEN HAVE DONE. AND GIVEN SORT
OF WHAT I WAS TOLD WAS A VERY
HIGH COST OF CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE I DON'T KNOW
FIFTY THOUSAND IS THE RIGHT
AMOUNT OR NOT- WHY DID WE MAKE
THAT NORMATIVE CHOICE TO
PREFERENCE ELECTRIC OVER. THE
HYDROGEN. BUT WE BELIEVE A GREAT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- WE WERE
WE WERE LOOKING TO MAKE THAT
KIND OF THE BIGGEST CLIMATE
IMPACT POSSIBLE WITH THIS THIS
FUNDING. AND GIVEN THE HIGH
NUMBER OF- DIESEL BUSES THAT
CURRENTLY OPERATE THE STATE YOU
WANTED TO. WE WANTED TO MAKE
THE- GREATEST IMPACT YOU KNOW
HAVE THE DOLLAR GO THE FURTHEST
SO THE ELECTRIC SCHOOL BUS
OPTIONS SEEM TO. PROVIDE THAT-
THAT OPPORTUNITY- SO THAT WAS
OUR OUR KIND OF REASONING FOR
GOING WITH ELECTRIC SCHOOL BUSES
RATHER THAN ALLOWING. A VARIETY
OF OTHERS AS SOME OTHER.
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS TO. OKAY A
BIT BECAUSE WHEN I TALK TO THEM
AGAIN AND THIS IS JUST ONE DATA
POINT BUT WHEN I TALK TO MY
LOCAL. TRANSIT AUTHORITY DID
EXPRESS ME THEY HAD CONCERNS
ABOUT THE HIGH COST OF CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE ASSOCIATE WITH
ELECTRIC. AND DEPENDING ON WHAT
THE COST A HUNDRED AND WAS GOING
TO BE IN A FEW YEARS HYDROGEN
COULD END UP BEING A LOT MORE
EXPENSIVE IT COULD BE CHEAPER
BUT THE UP FRONT COST OF
ELECTRIC WE'RE WE'RE QUITE HIGH
IN THEIR VIEW. AND AGAIN I DON'T
PRETEND TO BE AN EXPERT ON ALL
THIS BUT- YOU KNOW WHEN THAT THE
DECISION WE WANT TO DO IT MAKE
IT A LOCAL LEVEL BASED ON AND
THE PRICING AND DYNAMICS OF THE
MARKET AT THE TIME RATHER THAN.
I MEAN WHAT WHAT MAKING A PRETTY
BIG DECISION HERE ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS TO SAY. ELECTRIC
SCHOOL BUSES THE WAY TO GO IN MY
UNDERSTANDING THE DEBATE WHEN IT
COMES TO HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES
SUCH AS BUSES IS THAT. IT'S NOT
CLEAR WHICH TECHNOLOGIES BETTER
WHICH ONE WILL BE MORE COST
EFFECTIVE OVER THE LONG RUN. AND
SO I GUESS MY QUESTION IS SORT
OF. WHAT WERE THE DATA POINTS
OTHER THAN SORT OF I GUESS THE
COST ONE WHICH I'M NOT SURE I
FULLY UNDERSTAND- YEAH YOU KNOW
WHAT WERE THE REASONS THAT WE
CHOSE ELECTRIC. MORNING INTERNET
AREA BERMAN FINANCE OKAY THERE I
DON'T- SO JUST ANSWER THAT
QUESTION CENTER MAN THE WAY I
THINK OF IT IS WE'RE REALLY
TRYING TO BE AS CONSISTENT AS
POSSIBLE ACROSS SEVERAL OF THE
OTHER PROGRAMS BOTH- PROPOSALS
THAT WERE DONE- THAT FOR GRANT
PROGRAMS ADMINISTERED BY THE A.
R. B. AND- THE- ENERGY
COMMISSION LAST YEAR AS WELL AS
PROPOSALS IN THIS CURRENT
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THAT REALLY DO
. HIGHLIGHTED MINISTRATIONS
INTENT OVER ARCHING ON GOING AS
FAR DOWN THE ROAD AS ELECTRIC
VEHICLES AS WECAN AND YOU'RE
SAYING THAT NOT JUST AND- YOU
KNOW THE PUBLIC TRANSIT SECTOR-
BUT ALL ACROSS RIGHT SEVERAL-
INITIATIVES AND FOCUS ON ON.
ELECTRIFYING VEHICLES WHETHER
THAT BE FLEET VEHICLES OR
OTHERWISE. AND THAT'S REALLY
MORE- THE LANDS THAT WAS USED-
WHEN WE WERE CRAFTING THIS
PROPOSAL NOW THAT'S NOT TO SAY
THAT WE ARE COMPLETELY UNAWARE-
CERTAINLY SOME OF THE CONCERNS
THAT YOU'RE MENTIONING- SOME OF
THE YOU KNOW DIFFICULTIES
PRACTICALLY WHETHER THAT'S
BECAUSE OF THE DISTRCT AS- MAY
BE MORAL OR HAS. A LONGER ROUTE
THAN ONE AN ELECTRIC VEHICLE-
WOULD BE ABLE TO DO
REALISTICALLY WE WILL KEEP WILL
WE ARE ENGAGING CONVERSATIONS TO
TALK ABOUT SOME WAYS THAT. NO
THERE IF THERE ARE TWEAKS NEEDED
BUT AT THE MOMENT- THAT WAS THE
LENS THAT WAS USED FOR THIS
PROPOSAL. AND WE HAVE A HAND
FROM THE L. A. SO BEFORE GOING
BACK TO SENATOR MAN I'M GONNA
RECOGNIZED. THE OHIO. AT THANK
YOU SO TO SPEAK TO THAT-
QUESTION SENATOR MAN WE GET THIS
PART OF OUR REVIEW TOUGHEST
DISTRICT IT BRINGS YOUR ELECTED
. AND CHARGING STATE MY LOOK AT
PREVIOUS PROGRAM. AND A FULL
SIZE ELECTRIC BUS A FAIRLY HIGH
AND TRY STATE. A FOUR HUNDRED
DOLLAR FOR THE ELECTED SCHOOL
BUS FIFTY THOUSAND TRYING TO
STATION SEEMS TO BE. ABOUT WHAT
THE MARK PROCESS RIGHT NOW ARE
UNDER THOUGH THEY IS JUST DOWN.
THE COSTA TRANSIT MY PAY THEIR
IS A BIT DIFFERENT FROM THE BUS
AND IT'S CHARGING FOR STRUCTURE. AND AS FAR AS THE BUST. WE ARE
. AND I AROUND WE DON'T OF ANY
THE HAS TO IT LIKE US HYDROGEN
FUEL. BASED FOR SCHOOL THAT AS
FAR AS WE KNOW ELECT. SCHOOL BUS
LIKE TO SCHOOL BUSES ARE THE
ONLY KIND OF ZERO VEHICLE THAT
GONNA COMMERCIALLY FOR YOUR IN
RIGHT NOW. THAT'S VERY HELPFUL
THERE ARE SOME OTHER. THAT ARE
TO OUR JUST. THOSE CHECKS OF
VEHICLES INCLUDING THE ONE THAT
WAS CREATED IN YEAR'S BY AND-
BUT- THAT I THINK WAS WHAT I
CASE. TO DIMINISH MUST WHAT TYPE
OF THE- COULD BE FOR. IMPLEMENT
RIGHT NOW THAT'S VERY HELP HELP
ANSWERS ON- IF THERE ARE NO
HYDROGEN FUEL CELL. THE THAN YOU
REALLY PER ANYTHING I APPRECIATE
ANSWER I DO HAVE CONCERNS THAT
WE ARE CREATING A MARKET. AND
WE'RE PUSHING OURSELVES ON A
PATH WHERE IT RATHER THAN
LETTING THE MARKET SORT ITSELF
OUT- YEAH YOU KNOW WHAT ONE
THING THAT WAS STRIKING TO ME I
RECENTLY VISITED UC IRVINE'S.
TRANSPORTATION INSTITUTE. AND
ONE THING THEY TOLD ME WAS JUST
THAT IF WE TAKE ALL THE KNOWN
LITHIUM AND COBALT IN THE IN THE
WORLD. IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO MEET
OUR ANYWHERE CLOSE TO A SMALL
FRACTION OF OUR OUR BATTERY
NEEDS AND THAT WAS STRIKING TO
ME IN ADDITION TO THE PROBLEMS
OF WHAT WE DO WITH THESE
BATTERIES WHEN THEY RUN OFF. AND
I DO HAVE CONCERNS WERE PUSHING
REALLY HARD IN THE ELECTRIC
SPACE WITHOUT THINKING ABOUT THE
LONG TERM IMPLICATIONS FOR-
WHETHER THAT'S SUSTAINABLE BUT-
I APPRECIATE YOUR ANSWERS AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
SENATOR MENSEN RITUAL BOKE. I
JUST HAVE TO REACH AT ECHO
SENATOR MEN'S- COMMENTS THIS
MORNING BECAUSE I ACTUALLY HAVE
HAD THE SAME CONCERNS- THAT YOU
JUST EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR
SHARING- IN ASKING THOSE
QUESTIONS. I'M I ALSO WANTED TO
SORT OF ASK A QUESTION WITH
REGARDS TO- THE- ELECTRIC READ
AND THE ABILITY FOR US TO BE
ABLE TO. ASK THE SAME THESE
pBUSES ARE BE ABLE TO TRUST THEM
AND WHAT THE COST WILL BE
EVENTUALLY FOR THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND JUST AS- JUST IN
GENERAL- IF WE TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION ABOUT THE ELECTRIC
RATE AND OUR ABILITY TO- TO
SUPPORT OUR BUSES. AND STEPPED
VOTER- THAT WE PROBABLY BE FOUR-
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINE- GOOD
MORNING AGAIN IN A AN APARTMENT
OF FINANCE I THINK AS FAR AS
THAT QUESTION- SENSE
UNFORTUNATELY ONE OF THE MORE-
TRANSPORTATION- KIND OF
INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUES LIKE THAT
FALL OUTSIDE OF MY AREA AND MY
COLLEAGUE LINA'S AREA WITH
EDUCATION I DON'T KNOW THAT I
COULD SPEAK WITH A WHOLE LOT OF
EXPERTISE ON THE SUBJECT- I DO
KNOW. RIGHT EVEN THOSE ARE VALID
QUESTIONS CONCERNS I THINK FROM
MINISTRATIONS PERSPECTIVE WE I
LOOK AT IT AS WHERE YOU'RE
REALLY TRYING TO PLAY THE LONG
GAME IN TERMS OF SETTING- THE
STATE UP FOR SUCCESS BASED YOU
KNOW CONVERTING THERE STILL BY
CONVERTING DIESELS TO ELECTRIC
ZERO EMISSIONS THERE ARE STILL
SO MANY DIESEL BUSES AND CAN USE
INSERT IN CIRCULATION IN THE
STATE AND THAT HAS BOTH YOU KNOW
REAL IMPACTS FOR. THE HEALTH OF
STUDENTS AS WELL AS THE HEALTH
OF THE ENVIRONMENT OBVIOUSLY-
AND SO IT'S REALLY ABOUT-
PRIORITIZING THAT- AND
RECOGNIZING AT THE SAME TIME
THAT OUR PARTNERS- AT THE
DIFFERENT AGENCIES WHETHER IT'S-
THEIR RESOURCES BOARD OR WHOEVER
ELSE IN THAT SPACE OF REALIZING
THAT OUR PARTNERS TO HAVE A BIG
TASK AHEAD OF THEM WHEN IT COMES
TO- COMBATING SOME OF THOSE
OTHER CONCERNS WHETHER IT BE
INFRASTRUCTURE OR LIKE YOU SAID
COSTS TO. SCHOOL DISTRICTS I
WOULD NOTE THAT YOU KNOW OUR
HOPE OR INTENT WITH THIS
PROPOSAL IS THAT- IN THE LONG
TERM BECAUSE DIESEL BUSES CAN BE
SO MUCH ORE COSTLY TO MAINTAIN-
THAT IN THE LONG TERM SCHOOLS
WOULD SEE SAVINGS FROM FROM AS A
RESULT OF- ELECTRIFYING THEIR
FLEETS AND THAT WAS REALLY A LOT
OF THINKING BEHIND BEING ABLE TO
PAY THE FULL COST OF THE BUS OF
ELECTRIC BUS. CONVERSION IN THIS
CASE SUCH THAT- THE STATE IS
TAKING THE BRUNT OF THAT BURDEN
TO PROVIDE THE BUS AND THEN THE
DISTRICT COULD REALIZE COST
SAVINGS FROM THE OTHER PIECES OF
OWNING ELECTRIC BUS ROUTES THE
DIESEL BUS- IN IN THE MORNING
HERE- LONG TERM SO. THAT'S
HELPFUL I DON'T KNOW IF MY
COLLEAGUE AT THE ALIENS ANYTHING
ELSE AT ALL I WAS JUST GONNA SAY. MISTER IDEA DID VERY WELL WITH
HAVE HAVING LIMIT DECKS FOR. AND
I'M AND PRE MR IT IT IT IT THE
YOUR YOUR FEE ON THAT I THINK. I
THINK WHAT I'M GOING BACK TO IS
BASICALLY. AS MY COLLEAGUE
STATED EARLIER WE ARE DIRECTING
THESE FUNDS TO WHAT WE WOULD
LIKE TO ENVISIONED THOUGH I THE
INTENT AYE AT THE MERIT OF IT IS
. EXACTLY WHAT WE NEED TO DO I'M
JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT IF
MAYBE PERHAPS EVEN A LITTLE
FLEXIBILITY IN IN THE- IN
ALLOWING OUR LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS DECIDE. HOW TO HOW TO
PROCEED WITH AB ACQUIRING THESE
VEHICLES WHAT WOULD BE BEST FOR
THEM LOCALLY- IN WHETHER OR NOT
IT'S ELECTRIC VEHICLE OR
ELECTRIC BUS OR IF IT IS THEIR
EMISSIONS- BUS- SCENARIO SO.
THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S WHERE I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND AS TO MAYBE
PERHAPS GIVING A LITTLE
FLEXIBILITY TO OUR LOCAL SCHOOL
WOULD WORK BEST BOTH A- AND-
WITH INFRASTRUCTURE- WITHIN
THEIR THEIR- THEIR CAPACITIES
WITHIN THEIR COMMUNITY SO THAT'S
JUST THE CONCERN THAT I AM
HAVING- WITH REGARDS TO SAY
COULD THIS IS RICHARD WITH THIS
IS WHAT WE'RE GIVING YOU THIS IS
WHAT WE HAVE AND JUST MAKING A
VERY. LEAN YOU'RE A VERY
STRUCTURED- SO JUST A LITTLE BIT
IT JUST WANTING A SEAT THERE.
GREAT- DO YOU HAVE ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS ON. YEAH MAKE A
COMMENT. CENTER MILL YEAH I
DON'T WANT TO TAKE MY EARLIER
COMMENTS BE TAKING AS A
CRITICISM OF THIS PROJECT I'M
VERY MUCH IN FAVOR OF-
ELECTRIFIED AND GET MOVING IS
YOUR EMISSIONS AND- THIS SEEMS
LIKE A WORTHWHILE USE OF OUR
FUNDS PARTICULAR TIME WHEN THIS
ONE ACT MOST OF THIS AS I
UNDERSTAND WILL NOT COUNT
AGAINST AGAIN LINDA SO I APPLAUD
DEPARTMENT FINANCE DEPARTMENT
EDUCATION FOR- THIS APPROACH
AND- I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
WE'RE DOING IT RIGHT. REALLY DO
APPRECIATE. THE DIRECTIONALITY
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL HERE.
THE YOU. ARE AND- A. I. WE'VE
REYES. LOTS OF ISSUES HERE BUT
GOOD ONES AND THINGS TO THINK
ABOUT OVER THE NEXT MONTHS AS WE
MARCH TOWARD THE MAY REVISE. SO
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO ISSUE NUMBER
TWO. AND THANK OUR PANELISTS WHO
WERE HERE FOR ISSUE NUMBER ONE.
THE ISSUE NUMBER TWO IS
NUTRITION. AND OUR PANEL IS ALEK
SHOPE FROM THE DEPARTMENT AMY LEE FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE KIM
FRIENDS L. FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION AND WE'RE GONNA GO
IN THAT ORDER- SO WE'LL BEGIN
WITH OUR TROOP WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- AND MEMBERS ALLEN CHAU
PARTNERS FINANCE- IT IS THE
PRIORITY OF THE ADMINISTRATION
TO ADDRESS ISSUES AND FOOD AND
NUTRITION SECURITY- ENCOURAGE
HEALTHY DIETS AND ESTABLISH A
CLIMATE SMART SCHOOL FOOD SUPPLY
. PUZZLES AND THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET BILL OFF OF THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET INVESTMENTS
AND COMMITMENTS TO- IMPLEMENT
UNIVERSAL BILLS. SO
SPECIFICALLY- THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROVIDES FIVE HUNDRED AND
NINETY SIX MILLION- ONGOING
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND TO IMPLEMENT THE UNIVERSAL
SCHOOL MEALS PROGRAM- THAT WAS
INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET AT. THIS IS IN
ADDITION TO FIFTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS- WHAT NINETY GENERAL
FUND PROVIDED IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET FOR A TOTAL.
ADDITIONAL ANNUAL UNIVERSAL
SCHOOL MEALS BESSNER OF SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS. THIS AMOUNT IS BASED ON. ALL MEALS AT THE FEDERAL THREE
RATE- WILL END AT THE END OF
JUNE TWENTY TWENTY TWO- AN
AMOUNTS TO A TOTAL STATE
INVESTMENT OF ABOUT EIGHT
HUNDRED TWENTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE STATE BILL
PROGRAM- THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
ALSO INCLUDES COMPLIMENTARY
INVESTMENTS TO THE ROLL OUT. OF
UNIVERSAL BILLS- THIS INCLUDES
FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION.
ONE TIME PROP NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND TO PROVIDE SCHOOL
KITCHEN INFRASTRUCTURE GRANTS-
TO INCREASE LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES CAPACITY TO PROVIDE
FRESH AND NUTRITIOUS CLASS WILL
MEALS. IN ANTICIPATION OF
UNIVERSAL SCHOOL MEALS
IMPLEMENTATION- ALLOWABLE USES
FOR THIS FUNDING. PURCHASES OF
COOKING EQUIPMENT SERVICE
EQUIPMENT REFRIGERATION AND
STORAGE- TRANSPORTATION FACILITY
UPGRADES AND TRAINING FOR YOU TO
SERVICE STAFF- THE BUDGET ALSO
PROPOSES AN ADDITIONAL THREE
MILLION DOLLARS PROP NINETY
GENERAL FUND. FOR THE SCHOOL
BREAKFAST AND SUMMER MEALS
PROGRAM START UP GRANTS PROGRAM-
FOUR EIGHT BUDGET YOUR TOTAL OF
FOUR POINT ZERO ONE SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS. THESE FUNDS ARE
INTENDED TO ALSO BE ABLE TO
REIMBURSE COSTS INCURRED IN THE
CURRENT YEAR TO ENCOURAGE
SCHOOLS TO IMPLEMENT- OR
EXPANDED BREAKFAST PROGRAMS IN
PREPARATION FOR UNIVERSITY YES-
AND THAT CONCLUDES MY REMARKS
AND HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS AT
THE APPROPRIATE. TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WILL MOVE TO THE
LOWER. ANALYST'S OFFICE. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR SENATORS IN
NEARLY WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE SO THIS MORNING
WE WANTED TO SHARE OUR
ASSESSMENTS AND RECOMMENDATIONS
ON FEW OF THE GOVERNOR'S SCHOOL
NUTRITION PROPOSALS SPECIFICALLY
THE FIVE HUNDRED AND NINETY SIX
MILLION DOLLAR AUGMENTATION FOR
SCHOOL MEALS AND THE FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
ONE TIME FUNDING FOR ADDITIONAL
KITCHEN INFRASTRUCTURE AND
TRAINING GRANTS. FIRST ON THE
AUGMENTATION WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED THE
PROPOSED APPLICATION THIS
AUGMENTATION IS ALIGNED WITH
TRAILER LEGISLATION FROM THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET
PACKAGE REQUIRING THAT BEGINNING
IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE ALL
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS ARE REQUIRED
TO SERVE UNIVERSAL MEALS AND FOR
UNIVERSAL MEALS WE NEED
PROVIDING ONE FREE BREAKFAST AND
LUNCH FREE LUNCH PER SCHOOL DAY
ANY STUDENT AT RISK THAT IS
REQUESTING A MEAL. SO THAT IS ON
AUGMENTATION- THE REMAINDER OF
MY COMMENTS REALLY FOCUS ON THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO FIND
ADDITIONAL KITCHEN
INFRASTRUCTURE IN TRAINING
GRANTS. ON THIS POLLS WILL BE.
THE LEGISLATURE UP A REDUCED
AMOUNT OF ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR ADDITIONAL
KITCHEN INFRASTRUCTURE IN
TRAINING GRANTS. THIS IS ONE
THIRD OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
AMOUNT BUT IT MATCHES THE AMOUNT
THAT WAS PROVIDED IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. THE PRIMARY REASON
THAT WE RECOMMEND APPROVING A
REDUCED AMOUNT IS BECAUSE THE
STATE REALLY DOESN'T HAVE A
CLEAR SENSE AS TO THE TOTAL COST
OF KITCHEN INFRASTRUCTURE
UPGRADES. ASSOCIATED WITH
UNIVERSAL MEALS AT THIS TIME
ESPECIALLY SINCE THE STATE
ALREADY PROVIDED FUNDING FOR THE
SAME ACTIVITIES IN THE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO PERCENT. WE
EXPECT THAT SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION WILL BE AVAILABLE
AFTER JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY THREE EIGHT WHICH IS WHEN
ELOISE MUST REPORT HOW IT USED
THE FIRST ROUND OF FINDING. WE
ALSO RECOMMEND PRIORITIZING CAN
THIS FUNDING FOR IMPLEMENTING
UNIVERSAL MEALS RATHER THAN
INCORPORATION OF FRESH FOODS-
SCRATCH COOKING. SCHOOLS WILL
HAVE TO MANAGE A VARIETY OF NEAR
TERM CHALLENGES FOR THEIR SCHOOL
INTERESTING PROGRAMS INCLUDING
UNIVERSAL MEALS STAFFING
SHORTAGES AND INCREASED COSTS
FOR FOOD AND EQUIPMENT. FOR
THESE REASONS WE BELIEVE THAT
EDUCATIONAL FUNDING FOR SCRATCH
COOKING TO BE SOMEWHAT PREMATURE
AT THIS TIME. WE THINK THE
LEGISLATURE COULD REVISIT
FUNDING FOR BOTH UNIVERSAL MEALS
AND SCRATCH COOKING IN FUTURE
YEARS WANTS MORE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE DEMAND AND THE USE OF
THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO GRANTS
BECOME AVAILABLE. LASTLY THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER
MODIFYING THE FORMULA FOR THE
GRANTS TO TARGET DISTRICTS THAT
ARE MOST IMPACTED BY UNIVERSAL
MEALS. THE GOVERNOR'S COALS ALL
ALLOCATE A PORTION OF FUNDING TO
DISTRICTS WITH AT LEAST 30% OF
STUDENTS QUALIFYING FOR FREE OR
REDUCED PRICE MEALS. THIS
APPROACH LIKELY EXCLUDES SOME
DISTRICTS THAT WILL NEED TO
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE CAPACITY
TO SERVE UNIVERSAL MEALS.
SPECIFICALLY THOSE THAT
CURRENTLY DO NOT OFFER A SCHOOL
LUNCH AND OR SCHOOL BREAKFAST.
AND THOSE WITH LOWER SHARES OF
STUDENTS QUALIFYING FOR FREE OR
REDUCEDPRICE MEALS. TO ENSURE A
SMOOTHER IMPLEMENTATION THE
LEGISLATURE. COULD CONSIDER
ALLOCATING FUNDING BASED ON SOME
OF COMPOUND NEED. SUCH AS A PART
- HOW MANY MEALS A DISTRICT WILL
JUST UNDER. MEALS COMPARED TO
SOME PRIOR BASICALLY LEVEL. THAT
CONCLUDES MY TESTIMONY BUT HAPPY
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS
WILL MOVE TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. GIVE GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CAN FRIENDS AL
DIRECTOR OF NUTRITION SERVICES
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION. AND TODAY I'M
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND. THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION IS
GRATEFUL FOR THE INVESTMENTS ON
SCHOOL MEALS ENSURING ALL
STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO BOTH THE
NUTRITIOUS BREAKFAST. AND LUNCH
EACH SCHOOL DAY. THIS INVESTMENT
TRULY ELEVATES THE IMPORTANCE OF
HEALTHY SCHOOL MEALS. AND BRING
SHOWS THAT SCHOOL MALES ARE
VITAL ELEMENT TO IT STUDENTS
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE. IT ALSO
PROVIDES ELLIE AS WITH THE
FINANCIAL RESPITE TO MAKE IT
HAPPEN. STEADIES OF LONG
CONFIRMED THAT THERE'S INCREASED
PARTICIPATION AND SCHOOL MEALS
FROM ALL STUDENTS REGARDLESS OF
THEIR ECONOMIC STATUS WHEN MALES
ARE MADE AVAILABLE AT NO COST
FOR ALL. AND SADLY THE PANDEMIC
HAS TRULY REVEALED JUST HOW
ESSENTIAL SCHOOL MEAL PROGRAMS
ARE IN COMBATING FOOD INSECURITY
ACROSS ALL ECONOMIC LEVELS FOR
OUR STUDENTS- DECADES CALIFORNIA
HAS BEEN A NATIONAL LEADER AND
ESTABLISHING GREATER ACCESS FOR
SCHOOL MEALS. BUT IT DEPARTMENT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS-
PROVIDED HIGHLIGHTS OF THIS
YEAR'S INVESTMENTS FOR UNIVERSAL
MEALS AND IT REALLY DOES SET UP
OUR SCHOOLS FOR GREATER SUCCESS
IN IMPLEMENTING A SUSTAINABLE
UNIVERSAL MALES PROGRAM. THE
DESIGN OF THE CALIFORNIA
UNIVERSAL MAIL PROGRAM IS VERY
INTENTIONAL AND IT'S INTENDED TO
SUPPLEMENT NOT SUPPLANT THE
FEDERL MAIL REIMBURSEMENT SO
THAT WE CAN MAXIMIZE THE FULL
AMOUNT OF FEDERAL FUNDING. THE
FULL ON THE PROPOSED FOUR
HUNDRED AND MILLION FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
KITCHEN AFTER STRUCTURE AND
TRAINING ALLOCATION FORMULA.
HONORS THE NEEDS OF OUR ALLEY
AS- AND IT REALLY TAKES INTO
ACCOUNT THAT NOT ALL SCHOOLS ARE
THE SAME. AND REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER A SCHOOL HAS A VERY HIGH
PERCENTAGE OF PRE REDUCED PRICE
STUDENT ELIGIBILITY OR LOW OR
MODERATE THEY HAVE UNIQUE NEEDS
AND SCHOOLS NAY THE OPTIONS AND
THE CHOICE AND HOW TO USE THESE
VALUABLE RESOURCES. THE FUNDING
ALLOCATION ALLOW SCHOOLS TO
IMPLEMENT AND EXPAND SERVICES
FOR UNIVERSAL MALES AND
INNOVATIVE WAYS THAT MEET THEIR
NEEDS. WHETHER THAT IS INVESTING
IN MORE SCRATCH COOKING WHETHER
IT IS CREATING MORE POINT OF
SERVICE OPTIONS EXTENDING MILL
TIMES OFFERING BREAKFAST- MODELS
THAT MIGHT BE. DIFFERENT THAN
THEY HAVE IN THE PAST DEVELOPING
THEIR STAFF SKILL SETS PURCHASED
A NEW EQUIPMENT REPAIRING OR
PLUMBING ELECTRICAL NEEDS FOR
THE INFRASTRUCTURE OF THE
CAFETERIA AND KITCHEN. THE
RESPONSE TO THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO KITCHEN EFFORTS
DR FUNDS. HAVE BEEN VERY
POSITIVE WE ARE HEARING FROM
SCHOOLS THAT THEIR NEEDS WILL BE
ONGOING ESPECIALLY OVER THE NEXT
SEVERAL YEARS. AS WE COME OUT OF
THE PANDEMIC CONTINUE TO DEAL
WITH THE SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES AND
ALSO- ADDRESS DECLINING STUDENT
ENROLLMENT. SO OF THE ONE
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN
ELEAZAR WERE ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE
THIS YEAR'S FUNDING FOR THE
KITCHEN AT THE STRUCTURE
TRAINING FUNDS. NINETY FOUR
RIGHT JUST 94% REGISTERED FOR
THESE BONDS SEVEN NINE HUNDRED
AND FORTY ALLEY AS- AND WE ARE
CURRENTLY PARTNERING WITH UC
BERKELEY NUTRITION POLICY
INSTITUTE SURVEY OUR FOOD
SERVICE DIRECTORS ON UNIVERSAL
MEALS. IT'S A PRETTY
COMPREHENSIVE SURVEY THAT WILL
COLLECT CONCERNS NEEDS
IMPORTANT- DATASETS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO SUSTAIN UNIVERSAL
MILLS IN THE COMING YEARS. AND
WE'VE JUST RELEASED A SURVEY BUT
JESSICA AS OF LAST WEEK OVER A
HUNDRED EIGHTY HAVE COMPLETED
THE SURVEY AND THERE ANOTHER
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SEVEN IN
PROGRESS SO WE'LL HAVE MORE
RESULTS TO SHARE IN MID MARCH SO
IN CLOSING CALIFORNIA CONTINUES
TO LEAD THE WAY. AND LONG TERM
INVESTMENTS FOR THE OVERALL
HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF OUR
STUDENTS AND THEIR ACADEMIC
SUCCESS WE APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMITMENT AN ONGOING FUNDING OF
UNIVERSAL MALES AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AND-
LEGISLATURE ON THE KITCHEN
INFRASTRUCTURE PROPOSAL. THANK
YOU AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. ONE OF THE WEIRD ONE I
NOTICED THAT YOU OF A CANDLE
BURNING IN THE BACKGROUND IS
THAT AROMATHERAPY IS AT WHAT'S
HELPING YOU TESTIFY. I KNOW IT'S
NOT THANK YOU OKAY WELL I JUST
THOUGHT THAT. THE L. A. O. IN
THE FINANCE ARE LISTENING
CLOSELY IN CASE THEY NEED TO
FOLLOW THE LEAD SO. I HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS AND I'M-
EGGMAN MAYBE I'LL START WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND GO
TO FINANCER OF THE L. A. L. AND
THAT'S IT LAST YEAR. WHEN WE
WERE HAVING THE HEARING ON THIS
EXACT SAME TOPIC- MOST OF THE
SCHOOLS ACROSS CALIFORNIA CLOSED
THE NUTRITION PROGRAMS HAD
PLUNGED AND USAGE THERE WERE
SOME- SOME SCHOOLS THAT WERE
MAKING A VALIANT EFFORT TO GET
FOOD OUT. AND HAVE THEIR
STUDENTS EVEN THOUGH THEY WERE
CLOSE COMBINED PICK IT UP AND-
AND THERE'S NO REFERENCE CLEARLY
IN THE STAFF REPORT TO WHETHER
OR NOT OF THE MALES IN THE
PROGRAMS HAVE COME BACK TOTALLY
AS SCHOOLS HAVE REOPENED WHAT'S
THE STATUS. OR THE NUMBERS WHERE
THEY WERE PRE PANDEMIC AND
PEOPLE. ARE USING MALES AT
SCHOOLS AND I DON'T KNOW WHO
WANTS TO TAKE THAT FIRST LET'S
START WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND SEE IF THE OTHERS
WISH TO COMMENT. SHARES THANK
YOU CAN CONSULT APARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND- UNFORTUNATELY NO
THE NUMBERS HAVE NOT REBOUND AS
OF YET- WERE STILL FUNCTIONING
UNDER A HUNDRED SIXPENCE A VERS
BUT WHEN WE LOOK AT. MAIL COUNTS
IN SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY NINETEEN
PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC TWO LET'S
JUST TAKE BREAKFAST COUNTS IN
SEPTEMBER FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THEY ARE DOWN ABOUT TWO POINT.
NINE MILLION MEALS THAT WE ARE-
UNDER SERVING PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC AND I'M SORRY BECAUSE A
LOT OF TIMES THERE'S APPLES TO
APPLES YOU DON'T ROUGHLY WHAT
THE PERCENT OF TOTAL MALE STATUS
SO THAT WE HAVE. A CONTEXT WHERE
JOHN CENTER 20% LIKE WHAT'S THE
BIG DROP OFF WITH THAT NUMBER OF
NAMES. IT'S I WOULD HAVE TO RUN
THE NUMBERS TO GIVE YOU THAT THE
PERCENT CHANGE BUT IT HAS- IT
HAS BEEN A SIGNIFICANT DROP.
OKAY AND AT THE TIME WE WERE
DOING THIS LAST YEAR THERE WERE
EMERGENCY FUNDS. GOING TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND I THINK THEY WERE
SCHEDULED TO EXPIRE RIGHT ABOUT
THE TIME THE SCHOOL YEAR STARTED
TODAY EXPIRE OR THEIR CONTINUING
EMERGENCY FUNDS TO DISTRICTS ARE
WE DONE WITH THAT RIGHT NOW.
YEAH THERE'S BEEN SEVERAL
FEDERAL FUNDING OPTIONS
AVAILABLE TO SCHOOLS AND SO
THERE WERE SOME AS HER FRIENDS
THAT WENT OUT AND THOSE HAVE
BEEN EXPENDED. AND THEN IN
ADDITION- THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
RELEASED THE EMERGENCY COST
REIMBURSEMENT SO THAT PROVIDED A
FUNDING ALLOCATIONS OF THOSE
HAVE HAVE GONE OUT. AND THEN-
THEY JUST RELEASED A SUPPLY
CHAIN FUNDING AMOUNT THAT WE
WILL ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
ALLOCATING OUT TO SCHOOLS TO
HELP. WITH THE LOSS AND THE
INCREASE IN FOOD. COSTS AND
SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES THEY'RE
STILL MONEY COMING JUST NOT IN
THE SAME CATEGORY SO IT WAS
COMING AT THE HEART OF THE
PANDEMIC CORRECT. AND THEN. WITH
EXCUSE ME WE HAVE BEEN TALKING
IN THE THROUGH THE PANEL IN THE
STAFF REPORT ABOUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF WHAT FOR
CALLING UNIVERSAL MEALS AND I
KNOW THERE WAS A SIGNIFICANT
AUGMENTATION MADE LAST YEAR. IS
IT TOO EARLY TO KNOW EXACTLY-
HOW THAT'S BEING IMPLEMENTED AND
WHETHER IT'S WHILE WITH WHETHER
THE SCHOOLS ARE FAILING
THEMSELVES OF THAT. THEN MAYBE
WE'LL START WITH THE OF. THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND SEE
IF OTHERS WISH TO HAVE. I'M
SORRY- MISTER SHERMAN CAN YOU
REPEAT THAT IT'S BASICALLY THAT
THE UNIVERSAL MALES WAS CREATED.
DO WE UNDERSTAND HOW
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENTATION S.
B. YES- UNDER THE FEDERAL
WAIVERS THEY HAVE BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL AND THAT- THE SCHOOLS
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO- TO CONTINUE
TO DO NON CONGREGATE WHICH
TRADITIONALLY IS NOT. AN OPTION
AND- AS WELL AS OFFERING- THAT
BALK FOODS IN DOING AND
DIFFERENT CHOICES SO YES. IT HAD
THE UNIVERSAL MALES HAS BEEN
VERY SUCCESSFUL UNDER THE
FEDERAL- PROVISIONS OF THE
PANDEMIC AND WHEN YOU SAY NON
CONGREGATE WHAT DOES IT MEAN IN
THE TERMS OF THIS PROFILE I KNOW
CONTRA MEANS EVERYBODY SITS IN
THE CAFETERIA. LUNCH AND NOT
CONGREGATE TO SOMETHING ELSE
WHAT DOES IT MEAN. YES THE NON
CONGER GET. WOULD MEAN THAT THAT
THE STUDENTS ARE TAKING THE
MALES HOME THEY'RE NOT CONSUMING
THEM ON CAMPUS. OKAY THANK. ARM
OF OTHER QUESTIONS BUT I REALLY
WANT TO GIVE MY COLLEAGUES A
CHANCE AND SO LET ME ASK SENATOR
TROUBLED YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
ON THE SIDE. YES SO- IT KIND OF
FOLLOWS THE PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THAT SENATOR SKINNER- MOVE
FORWARD LAST YEAR WITH REGARDS
TO. TRYING TO HAVE ARE
IMPLEMENTED A UNIVERSAL MEALS-
THROUGH OUR TO OUR SCHOOL
SYSTEM. AND ONE OF THE COMMENT
THAT ONE OF THE COMMENTS THAT
SHE MADE- AT OUR IN OUR
COMMITTEE WAS. THE FACT THAT WE
WEREN'T MAXIMIZING THE MATCHING
FUNDS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. SO MY QUESTION IS
MORE OF A WITH THE PROGRAM IS
THAT WE ARE- PROPOSING RIGHT NOW
WITH THE BUDGET- THEY WERE
PROPOSING RIGHT NOW. WITH THAT
MAXIMIZE THE MATCHING FUNDS FROM
THE FEDERAL. GOVERNMENT. EL SHOW
DEPARTMENT FINANCE- I THINK THAT
AS PART OF- ONE THING OF YOU
KNOW COUPLE THINGS THAT
HIGHLIGHT AS PART OF UNIVERSAL
NEEDLES PLANTATION- IN THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE FROM LAST
YEAR- WHAT WE REQUIRED ALL-
ELEAZAR THAT ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
THE COMMUNITY- ELIGIBILITY
PROVISION TO- ENROLL IN THIS
PROGRAM OR ONE OF THE OTHER
OTHER- FEDERAL PROVISIONS- YOU
KNOW BY THE- BEGINNING. OF THE
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE SCHOOL
YEAR. IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
MAXIMIZE. THE FEDERAL FUNDS TO
SUPPORT THAT COMES FROM BEING. A
PART OF THOSE PROGRAMS- I MIGHT
DIFFER I GUESS TO MY COLLEAGUE
AT- CD E. S. R. AS AS FAR AS-
EDUCATION- AT THE LOCAL LEVEL OF
ANY OTHER EFFORTS TO- TO.
EXCISES FEDERAL FUNDS BUT YOU
KNOW WE IT IS OUR INTENTION I
OUR DESIRE FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND SCHOOLS TO CONTINUE TO- YOU
KNOW COLLECT COLLECT- YOU KNOW
THE STUFF FREE AND REDUCED PRICE
NO FORMS AND YET BE ABLE TO
MAXIMIZE THE FUNDING. FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN THAT
REGARD AS WELL. DO YOU WANT
OTHER STATES I THINK SHE I THINK
HE HAD SOMEONE ELSE THAT WANTED
. THEN LET ME ASK IF THE L. A.
O. BORDERS CDP WISHES TO. F. ED
TO THAT DISCUSSION. NOBODY'S
MOVING SO I'M GATHERING THEY
DON'T HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD.
CENTER SO ONE LAST QUESTION AND-
THIS WAR- MONTHS CA FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- THE
PROPOSING FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR SCHOOL
KITCHEN INFRASTRUCTURE. AND WE
UNDERSTAND BASED ON OUR PAST
COUPLE MEETINGS- WE'VE COME TO
QUITE THE UNDERSTANDING OF THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE NEEDS THAT
ARE- WE'RE HAVING IN IN HIGHER
EDUCATION THAT WHICH IS IN THE
BILLIONS. JUST KIND OF CURIOUS
AS TO WHY FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR SCHOOL
KITCHEN INFRASTRUCTURE. SURE
THIS IS THE- SORT OF PROCESS- I
THINK THAT YOU KNOW AS AS- I MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION IT NOTED EARLIER- YOU
KNOW THERE IS A NEW ENTRY ROBUST
AND THE CURRENT YEAR FOUR- D.
THE- KITCHEN INFRASTRUCTURE
FUNDS- YOU KNOW AND WE SEE THAT
AS SORT OF A CONTINUING. ONGOING
NEED- I THINK WE WANTED TO BE
ABLE. TO YOU KNOW TAKE
ADVANTAGE- AND UTILIZE. THE
BAILABLE- ONE TIME RESOURCES- TO
BE ABLE TO EXPAND- THIS PROGRAM-
MAKE MAKE THIS FUNDING. FOR
IMPACTFUL FOR MORE- FOR MORE
ELEAZAR- ESPECIALLY. SORT OF
NOTING A LOT OF THESE NEEDS-
THAT THAT YOU KNOW THAT SCHOOLS
HAVE AS AS THEY THEY KIND OF
MOVED TOWARDS THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF A PERSON FEELS. SO ONE LAST
QUESTION HOW DID. WE ARRIVE AT
THE FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS. MARK. I GUESS
AS FAR AS THE SPECIFIC SIZE I
THINK WE JUST WANTED TO YOU KNOW
BE ABLE TO USE THE AVAILABLE ONE
TIME RESOURCES- UNDERSTANDING
YOU KNOW DAD'S- FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION THAT HAS ALLOWED
US TO. EXPAND THIS PROGRAM- AND
IN A FEW DIFFERENT WAYS- THE
WHILE WE CAN YEAH EXPANDED THE
SPACE ALLOCATION FOR ANY SCHOOL
THAT OPS IN- FROM TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND-
WE HAVE LOWERED THE FREE AND
REDUCED PRICE MEALS THRESHOLDS-
FOR THE FIRST PART OF THE
DISAPPOINTING FROM FIFTY
PERCENT- 230% WHICH I THINK FROM
SOME OF THE INITIAL DATA WE ST
WORK. WHAT AN INCREASE IN
ELIGIBILITY- BY ABOUT THIRTY
PERCENT- LIAISE ARE OFTEN- AND
THEN YEAH FINALLY THIS STATE
INCREASED ABOUT IT ALSO- MAKES
IT POSSIBLE TO PROVIDE THE
SECOND PART OF THIS NO FUNDING-
FOR ELEAZAR THAT. ARE YOU KNOW
WILL COMMIT TO SERVING AT LEAST
40% OF TOTAL MEALS PREPARED FROM
SCRATCH OR SPEED SCRATCH
BEGINNING- IN TWENTY TWENTY
THREE AND FOUR. BECAUSE THAT THE
COMPLETE YOUR QUESTIONS YES
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU SENATOR
MAN. I JUST WANTED TO FOLLOW UP
ON MY COLLEAGUES QUESTIONS- CAN
I THREE SCHOOL AGE KIDS IN- AS I
SAID BEFORE THE PLURAL OF
ANECDOTE IS NOT DATA AND I'M
VERY WELL AWARE THAT BUT I DO
WANT TO DESCRIBE THEIR
EXPERIENCES. FOR MOST OF LAST
YEAR WITH THE RECEIVE FOR THEIR
LUNCH WHICH THERE IS A VERY
EXCITED TO GET WAS LITERALLY TWO
PIECES OF BREAD AND A PIECE OF
MEAT- AND WHEN WE ASKED ABOUT
WHY THAT WAS THE CASE FOR MOST
OF LAST YEAR SCHOOL YEAR. I WAS
BECAUSE OF STAFFING AND A LACK
LACK OF KITCHEN RESOURCES. THIS
YEAR I'M TOLD IT'S GOTTEN A
LITTLE BETTER OCCASIONALLY THEY
HAVE PIZZA OR SOME OTHER OPTION
BUT IT'S- BY AND LARGE THE SAME
. AND SO I GUESS TO FOLLOW UP ON
ON SENATOR- SHOWBOATS QUESTION.
WHY ADD MORE MONEY WHEN THERE'S
CLEARLY AT LET IT SEEMS IN AND
THIS SEEMS TO BE AT I'VE MAYBE I
SHOULD ADD PHRASES IN THE FORM
OF A QUESTION. IT IS MY-
CHILDREN'S EXPERIENCE. UNIQUE OR
IS THAT SOMETHING WE'RE SEEING
IS- BOTTLENECK. AND IN TALKING
WITH SOME DIFFERENT TEACHERS
GROUPS OUT THERE. AND SCHOOL
WORKERS. IT DAVE EXPRESSED ME
SOME SIMILAR CONCERNS THAT THERE
IS A BOTTLENECK. THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH STAFF THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
KITCHEN RESOURCES. TO PREPARE
THE TYPES OF MEALS THAT WE'D
LIKE TO HAVE FOR UNIVERSAL
MEALS. AND SO I APPLAUD THIS
PROGRAM I THINK IT'S REALLY
GREAT BUT OUR OUR THE RESOURCES
THERE AND IF TO REALLY KIND OF
MAKE THIS- YOU KNOW HOLISTIC IN
THE WAYS THAT YOU WERE
ENVISIONING. AND IF NOT THEN WHY
NOT DEFAULT TO SOME OF THE
ALEJO'S RIET RECOMMENDATIONS OF
SCALING IT BACK TO THOSE ALLEY
AS- THAT NEED IT THE MOST RATHER
THAN MAKING IT TRULY UNIVERSAL-
AND I'M I'M ALL IN FAVOR
UNIVERSAL LUNCHES UNIVERSAL
MEALS I THINK THIS IMPORTANT-
MORAL SIGNAL BUT BUT- IF WE
CAN'T WRAP THIS UP. AND ALSO WE
CAN'T SUSTAIN THE STAFF THAT WE
NEED TO REALLY KEEP IT GOING.
OVER ON AN ONGOING BASIS- YOU
KNOW IF WERE USING ONE TIME
FUNDS WOULDN'T IT MAKE MORE
SENSE. TO PUT IN THOSE DISTRICTS
THAT NEED IT THE MOST- SURE SO I
GUESS I GUESS I WOULD I WOULD.
GO BACK TO- MY PREVIOUS POINT-
YOU KNOW BY BY MAKING THOSE
CHANGES- YOU KNOW OFF OF THE-
TWENTY. TWENTY ONE KITCHEN
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING- WE ARE
TRYING TO MAKE THIS YOU KNOW
FUNDING. AVAILABLE ADD AS MANY
ELEAZAR POSSIBLE INCLUDING YOU
KNOW THE ONES THE ONES THAT WE
NEED IT MOST- I THINK IN
RESPONSE- YOU KNOW SORT OF. WHAT
ABOUT MAKING A KIND OF HOLISTIC
YOU KNOW IMPROVEMENT AS WE GO
TOWARDS UNIVERSAL MEALS- I THINK
THAT IS YOU KNOW ONE OF OUR
INTENTIONS AND ONE OF THE
REASONS THAT WE HAVE ALSO ADDED
THIS FUNDING FOR- SCRATCH
COOKING I THINK WE SORT OF SEE
THIS AS AN IMPORTANT OWNER OF
UNIVERSAL MEALS RIGHT- YEAH
INCREASING. THE QUALITY OF MEALS
I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
STEP- IN TERMS OF JUST
INCREASING THE- PARTICIPATION- I
THINK ONE OF OUR HOPES AND
INTENTIONS. WITH THIS AS WELL
RIGHT IS INCREASING THE QUALITY
MEALS INCREASING THE
PARTICIPATION- YEAH WILL WILL
INCREASE B. THE REVENUE THAT-
YEAH ELEAZER WILLS ARE ABLE TO
GENERATE FROM THIS- I THINK
WE'VE RELEASE. YOU KNOW
ANECDOTALLY- OF SCHOOLS THAT IT
GOT KIND OF EXPANDED OR STOOD UP
PROGRAMS YEAH. THE BREAKFAST
PROGRAM FOR EXAMPLE- YOU KNOW
BEING ABLE TO- YOU KNOW USED
USED ADDITIONAL REVENUE
GENERATED FROM INCREASED
PARTICIPATION TO INCREASE- STAFF
HOURS. BUT I GUESS JUST A FOLLOW
UP AND THEN I LIKE TO HEAR FROM
LA- I'M I MEAN WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT IS USING ONE TIME
FUNDING IN THE HOPES OF
JUMPSTARTING ONGOING FUNDING- I
MEAN AGAIN I PLUGGED THE GOAL
HERE BUT BUT IF WE'RE GONNA TALK
ABOUT ONGOING FUNDING AND A
PERMANENT SHIFT. IN HOW WE
PROVIDE MEALS. LET'S TALK ABOUT
THAT IN THE CLASS- BUT LETS. YOU
KNOW TO ME IT SEEMS
INAPPROPRIATE TO BE USING ONE
TIME FUNDING. WHEN WE KNOW THAT
THEIR BOTTLENECKS THAT WILL
REQUIRE ONGOING FUNDING TO
ADDRESS I MEAN. AGAIN I DON'T
KNOW HOW YOU NEED MY KIDS
EXPERIENCES BUT- I'M NOT I'M
JUST NOT HEARING IT IS NOT
UNIQUE. AND SO WOULDN'T IT BE
BETTER IN IN THE FACE OF
CONSTRAINED RESOURCES TO. THE
SCALE THIS TO THE SCHOOL ELEAZAR
SCHOOLS THAT NEED IT THE MOST IN
THE WAY THE L. A. O. HAS ITS
PROPOSED- YOU KNOW AND I GUESS
THE OTHER QUESTION I HAVE IS
WHAT. HOW MUCH IS FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS TO GET US
TO CENTER TOWBOATS QUESTION.
WHAT DOES THAT GET US AS FAR AS
KITCHEN UPGRADES AS FAR AS
STAFFING INCREASES AS FAR AS-
MEALS. YOU KNOW IF THE GOAL HERE
IS TO CREATE SOMETHING MORE
SUSTAINABLE I I'D BE INTERESTED
IN KNOWING SOARED HOW MANY
KITCHENS THIS THAT UPGRADE- HOW
MUCH STAFF DOES THAT GET US. OUT
HOW MANY SCHOOLS CAN ACTUALLY
GET TO PROVIDE YOU KNOW GOOD.
HEALTHY MEALS TO ALL THEIR
STUDENTS. BUT MAYBE I'D LIKE TO
FROM LA HERE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MAN IMMEDIATELY WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE I
THINK YOUR COMMENT SPEAKS TO
THEIR NUMBER BUT THE CONCERNS
THAT WE RAISED IN OUR TESTIMONY
ENACT ANALYSIS AS WELL- ARE
UNDERSTANDING THE SITUATION IS I
DISTRICTS REALLY ARE STARTING IN
VERY DIFFERENT STARTING POINTS.
WHEN IT COMES TO UNIVERSAL MEALS
YOU HAVE SOME DISTRICTS THAT
MEET NOT HAVE A VERY ROBUST
SCHOOL LUNCH AND SCHOOL
BREAKFAST- PROGRAM AND THEY WILL
BE EXPECTED TO SERVE OR BE ABLE
TO SERVE ALL OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
TESTING CAMILLE'S FROM EITHER
LUNCH OR BREAKFAST. AND SO I
THINK RIGHT NOW IT'S JUST-%
CONCERNS OVER HOW AND THE FUNDS
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PROPOSING IS BEING TARGETED AND
WE DON'T NECESSARILY SEE IT
BEING TARGETED BASED OFF OF SOME
MEASURE OF CAPACITY NEED. TO
SORT OF ACCOUNT FOR THOSE I
DISTRICTS THAT MIGHT NOT HAVE A
ROBUST. SCHOOL SCHOOL MEAL
PROGRAM IT WILL NEED TO EXPAND
IT SIGNIFICANTLY TO MEET THE NEW
C. REQUIREMENTS STARTING IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND THE
OTHER THING WE WANT TO MENTION
IS ANYTHING. BOTH YOU ARE
SENATOR MAN AND SENATOR CHOI
BOGUE SORT OF SPOKE TO LAST IS
WE CURRENTLY DO NOT HAVE A
DEMAND I UNDERSTAND OF WHAT THE
DEMAND IS FOR KITCHEN
INFRASTRUCTURE UPGRADES
ASSOCIATED WITH UNIVERSAL MEALS.
I THINK WE HAVE A SENSE AS TO
WHAT- IT DISTRICTS. A FAIR
NUMBER OF ADDITIONAL TEACHING
RESOURCES TO NEED ADDITIONAL
NEEDS BUT WE DON'T NECESSARILY
HAVE A SENSE AS TO WHETHER OR
NOT THAT FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION WILL MEET THAT NEED WILL
EXCEED THAT NEED. AND SO-
RECOMMENDATION WAS REALLY TO
PROVIDE PROVIDE PROVIDE A
REDUCED AMOUNT UNTIL MORE
INFORMATION COMES AVAILABLE AND-
BASED OFF- AND MYSTERIES ELS-
TESTIMONY FROM CD IT SOUNDS LIKE
THERE SHOULD BE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION THAT WILL BE MADE
AVAILABLE IN MID MARCH TO SORT
OF HELP GAUGE WHETHER OR NOT THE
FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
PROPOSED. WHAT KIND OF S. THAT
NEEDS SOME OF THAT NEED FOR AN
ADDITIONAL. TEACHING
INFRASTRUCTURE UPGRADES. I THINK
I'M JUST TRYING TO. ABOUT THE
REASON WE PROPOSE- THE LET
PROVIDE WOULD DO AMOUNT REALLY
HELP STABILIZE THE SYSTEM WHEN
IT TO WILL WE RECKON THAT THIS
ARE COUNTING LOT OF. FACTORS
INTO SOME OF WHICH ARE REAL TO
STAFFING SHE AND WE THINK GIVING
THEM THE TIME TO REALLY
DESTABILIZE THEIR OPERATIONS
FOCUS ON UNIVERSAL MEALS AND
THEN MAYBE LATER ON APPROACH AND
SORT OF A DRESS AT SCRATCH
COOKING AND FIND WAYS TO
INCORPORATE MORE SCRATCH COOKING
IT MAY BE A MORE REASONABLE SORT
OF MIDLINE APPROACH- THAT WOULD
BE THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL FOR
IMPLEMENTATION PURPOSES. THANK
YOU IS IT AS A VERY HELPFUL AND
THOUGHTFUL ANSWERED I GUESS I
SAYS LOOK AT UNIVERSAL LUNCHES
SOUNDS GREAT BUT IF WE WANT THIS
TO BE MORE THAN JUST A SLOGAN WE
HAVE TO YOU KNOW REALLY CROSS
ARE TEASING DAUGHTER EYES WE
HAVE TO. HAVE THE DATA THAT THAT
MISLEADS REFERRING TO- IN IN THE
MEANTIME MAYBE IT'S PREFERABLE
YOU KNOW MY KIDS DON'T NEED FOR
A LUNCH- YOU KNOW IT IT'S A
GREAT PART TO HAVE BEEN AND I
GET HAT WE WE'RE KIND OF THE
STIGMATIZING THIS BUT- TO EXTENT
THAT YOU KNOW CERTAIN SCHOOLS
MAY NEED THIS PROGRAM MORE THAN
OTHERS AND WE'RE NOT OPERATING
IN THE SPACE OF. UNLIMITED
RESOURCES NOR DOES THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSED ENOUGH
RESOURCES TO REALLY MAKE THIS
HOLISTIC ACROSS THE BOARD- YOU
KNOW I I'M EAGER FOR MORE DATA
BUT BUT I'M INCLINED TO SUPPORT
THE COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE AS. WELL AS L. A. O. THANK YOU.
OUR ROAD SHOW BOOK. JUST ONE
LAST COMMENT- THAT I REALLY. THE
NOTION OF HOW. CAPACITY VERSUS
BASELINE. ESPECIALLY WHENIT
COMES TO THIS- NEW TERRITORY
THERE WERE THERE WERE EXPLORING-
MOVING FORWARD. I'M WITH YOU SEE
THAT IT WOULD BE THE MOST
HELPFUL. FOR SCHOOLS THAT DO NOT
ALREADY HAVE THE TO ME A PROGRAM
SO I JUST WANTED TO PUT THAT ON
RECORD THERE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU END UP. I THANK THE
PANELISTS AND I THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR- REALLY- HAVING A
VERY GOOD INFORMATIVE DISCUSSION
ON THAT ITEM. GONNA MOVE OR OR
THANK THE PANELISTS BURKE.
BROUGH TOUR ABOUT TO MAKE A
RETURN APPEARANCE SO WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO ISSUE THREE MULTI
LINGUAL LIBRARIES. OUR PANEL IS
OUT SHOPE FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE EMILY FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
ALICIA MORENO RAMIREZ FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WILL
TAKE THEM IN THAT ORDER AND WILL
WELCOME MISTER SHOW BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. HEY ELIGIBLE FINANCE-
TO THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSES TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ONETIME PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND TO
CREATE THE MULTILINGUAL
CLASSROOM LIBRARY GRANT
PROGRAMS. TO ALLOW SCHOOLS TO
ESTABLISH OR EXPAND SCHOOL OR
CLASS CLASSROOM LIBRARIES.
OFFERING CULTURALLY RELEVANT
TAX- FUNDS WILL BE ALLOCATED TO
SCHOOLS MEETING MINIMUM
THRESHOLDS FOR FREE AND REDUCED.
PRICE MEALS PERCENTAGE CAN IN
WHISTLER PERCENTAGE- AND CAN BE
USED TO BUY BOOKS TO ESTABLISH A
SCHOOL OR CLASSROOM LIBRARIES
FOR STUDENTS IN PRESCHOOL
THROUGH. THIRD. GRADE- THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE L. L. IF
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND LEAVE WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AGAIN. OUR ANALYSIS ON THE
GOVERNOR'S MULTILINGUAL BOOKS
PROPOSAL WILL ONLY BE RELEASED
LATER TODAY BUT I DID WANT TO
SHARE OUR ASSESSMENT AND
RECOMMENDATION ON THIS PROPOSAL
FROM THAT ANALYSIS. OVERALL WE
HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THE
IMPACT OF THIS PROPOSAL WE FIND
THAT SCHOOLS HAVE A VARIETY OF
EXISTING FUNDING SOURCES THERE
WHICH THEY CAN FIND ADDITIONAL
MULTI LINGUAL AND CULTURALLY
RELEVANT BOOKS PRIMARILY THROUGH
LCS FAST I MEAN FUNDING FORMULA
FOR SCHOOLS. IN ADDITION TO
SIGNIFICANT RECENT ONE FUN ONE
TIME FUNDING FROM THE COMIC
RELIEF FUNDS STATE LOTTERY
REVENUE PRIVATE DONATIONS JUST
TO NAME A FEW. WE THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION'S APPROACH OF
PROVIDING RESTRICTED FUNDING FOR
CERTAIN EARLY LITERACY
ACTIVITIES IS NOT CONSISTENT
WITH ORIGINAL LEGISLATIVE INTENT
THAT AT LEAST LOCALLY DETERMINED
AND FIND PRIORITIES UNDER LCS
FAST FURTHERMORE TO DATE HAS
BEEN VERY LITTLE RESEARCH ON THE
IMPACT OF HAVING MORE
MULTILINGUAL BOOKS IN SCHOOL
LIBRARIES ON CHILDREN'S
LITERACY. CHILDREN COULD ALSO
ACCESS SUCH BOOKS FROM THEIR
LOCAL PUBLIC LIBRARY
ADDITIONALLY IT PROVIDING MORE
BOOKS IN SCHOOL AND CLASSROOM
LIBRARIES WOULD NOT DIRECTLY
IMPROVE OR RESULT IN EFFECTIVE
INSTRUCTION WHICH WOULD BENEFIT
MOST STUDENTS WE THINK OTHER
STATE INITIATIVES COULD BETTER
SUPPORT ENGLISH LEARNERS AS
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF.
BILINGUAL TEACHERS ARE PROVIDED
FOR TRAINING FOR TEACHERS TO
SUPPORT ENGLISH LEARNERS BECAUSE
OF THESE REASONS WE RECOMMEND TO
THE LEGISLATURE REJECTS THE
PROPOSED FUNDING FOR MULTI
LINGUAL BOOKS THEREBY FREEING UP
TWO HUNDRED MILLION FOR OTHER
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES THAT
CONCLUDES MY COMMENTS AND HAPPY
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU AND.
THEN WILL MOVE TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR- OF THE TEAM. HEY
LISA MARIE MARY'S. OF THE MOST
LEGAL SO DIVISION AT CD ON THE
OF THE DIFFERENT OF PUBLIC AND-
WE'RE PLEASED TO SEE THIS
PROPOSAL IT RELATES TO
SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN'S.
STATEWIDE LITERACY AND BY
LITERACY CAMPAIGN. REACHING
LITERACY BY THIRD GRADE HAS LONG
BEEN A GOAL OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS A KEY BENCHMARK AND
MEASURING AND PREDICTING STUDENT
SUCCESS. WE MUST TAKE BOLD
ACTION TO HELP STUDENTS MEET
THIS IMPORTANT MILESTONE AND PUT
THEM ON A PATH FOR LIFELONG
LEARNING AS OPPOSED TO A PATH
THAT INCREASES THE LIKELIHOOD
THAT THEY WILL DROP OUT OF
SCHOOL. OR END UP IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. OVER
70% OF THE INMATES AND AMERICA'S
PRISONS CANNOT READ ABOUT THE
FOURTH GRADE LEVEL THAT NEEDS TO
STOP. AND THERE'S NO BETTER TIME
THAN THE PRESENT. THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL BREAKS NICELY WAS
SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN'S MILLION
BOOKS CAMPAIGN TO PROVIDE
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES WITH
ACCESS TO TAX. ONE STUDY FOUND
THAT YOUNG CHILDREN WHO READ
FIVE TIMES DAILY WELL HERE
NEARLY ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
WORDS BY THE TIME THEY TURN FIVE
YEARS OF AGE DURING THEIR
LANGUAGE PROFICIENCY AND
ESTABLISHING A STRONG FOUNDATION
FOR ACADEMIC SUCCESS. READING TO
THIS EXTENT REQUIRES ACCESS TO
MANY BOOKS AND THOUGHTFUL
CURATION OF LIBRARIES TO BE MOST
APPROPRIATE TO THE DEVELOPMENTAL
CULTURAL LINGUISTIC AND
READABILITY NEEDS. THE AMERICAN
LIBRARY ASSOCIATION LIBRARY BILL
OF RIGHTS ASSERTS THAT BOOKS AND
OTHER LIBRARY RESOURCES SHOULD
BE PROVIDED FOR THE INTEREST
FORMATION AND ENLIGHTENMENT OF
ALL PEOPLE- I THANK THE LIBRARY
SERVICE. MOREOVER IT'S IMPORTANT
TO RECOGNIZE THAT AS OUR SCHOOLS
AND COMMUNITIES BECOME
INCREASINGLY DIVERSE BOTH
CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT NEED TO
REFRESH SCHOOL LIBRARIES MANY OF
WHICH HAVE AVERAGE COPYRIGHT
DATES IF TWENTY YEARS OLDER
OLDER AND ARE NOT REFLECTIVE OF
TODAY'S DEMOGRAPHIC. THE
PROPOSED INVESTMENT WILL HELP
ENSURE MULTI LINGUAL AND
CULTURALLY RELEVANT TAX CAN BE
MADE ACCESSIBLE TO CHILDREN IN
PRESCHOOL THROUGH THIRD GRADE.
SCHOOL LIBRARIES AND CLASSROOM
LIBRARIES TO PROMOTE LITERACY IN
MULTIPLE LANGUAGES. MULTIPACK
MULTI LEVEL TAX WILL PROMOTE
MORE EQUITABLE REPRESENTATION OF
DIVERSE CULTURAL. EXPERIENCES AS
PART OF LITERACY BY LITERACY OR
EVEN MULTI LITERACY DEVELOPMENT
IN YOUNG CHILDREN WHEN THE BRAIN
IS MOST RECEPTIVE TO EXPANDING
LANGUAGE LEARNING. WHAT ILLEGAL
RESOURCES ARE ESSENTIAL TO
SUPPORT LITERACY AND BY LITERACY
DEVELOPMENT IN CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS AND THESE RESOURCES ARE
OFTEN THE LEAST ACCESSIBLE
CALIFORNIA CLASSROOMS DUE TO
FACTORS SUCH AS COST. ACCESS TO
THESE TAX WILL PUT WITHIN REACH
CRITICAL LEARNING RESOURCES FOR
EMERGENT MULTILINGUAL STUDENTS
ENJOY A LANGUAGE IMMERSION
CLASSROOMS WHERE THEY'RE
LEARNING ACADEMICS AND
DEVELOPING A LANGUAGE IN BOTH
ENGLISH AND A LANGUAGE OTHER
THAN ENGLISH. THEY ARE CURRENTLY
REPORTED ONE THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED NINETY MULT LINGUAL
CLASSROOMS IN CALIFORNIA HAS A
TWENTY NINETEEN. AND WITH
GROWING INTEREST IN EXPANDING
DUAL LANGUAGE PROGRAMS LEARNERS
NEED EQUITABLE ACCESS TO HIGH
QUALITY LITERATURE AND LEVEL TAX
IN VARIOUS LANGUAGES IN ADDITION
TO ENGLISH IN ORDER TO DEVELOP
DEEP LITERACY PROFICIENCY THAT
WILL BENEFIT ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL
ENGAGEMENT. DISPARITIES ALSO
NOTED IN THE NUMBER OF RESOURCES
AVAILABLE IN ENGLISH COMPARED TO
THE RESOURCES ACCESSIBLE IN
LANGUAGES OTHER THAN ENGLISH IN
SCHOOL AND CLASSROOM LIBRARIES
AS WELL AS IN PUBLIC LIBRARIES.
FURTHER MULTI LINGUAL SCHOOL AND
CLASSROOM LIBRARIES CONSERVA
SOCIO OKAY SOCIO EMOTIONAL AND
ACADEMIC SUPPORTS FOR THE OVER
ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND NEWLY ARRIVED IMMIGRANT
AND REFUGEE STUDENTS. AS A
TRANSITION IT CALIFORNIA'S
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM. MULTI
LINGUAL TEXT PROVIDING STUDENTS
STEPPING STONE INTO ENGLISH
LANGUAGE PROFICIENCY AS WELL AS
A FIRM STUDENTS CULTURES AND
HOME LANGUAGE. SUPPORTING
MULTILINGUAL LEARNERS TO DEVELOP
STRONGER SKILLS IN THEIR HOME
LANGUAGE IS ALSO AN EQUITY ISSUE
THAT LEADS TO STRONGER ENGLISH
LANGUAGE ACQUISITION. RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT LITERACY AND HOME
LANGUAGE AN ONGOING PRACTICE
READING AND WRITING IN THAT
LANGUAGE CAN MOST READILY
FACILITATE THE ACQUISITION OF
LITERACY AND AN ADDITIONAL
LANGUAGE SUCH AS ENGLISH. AS
MANY LITERACY SKILLS CAN BE
TRANSFERRED ACROSS LANGUAGES.
MULTILINGUAL AND CULTURALLY
RELEVANT TAX BENEFIT LEARNERS IN
OTHER WAYS AS WELL FOR EXAMPLE
SEEING A REPRESENTATION OFONESELF IS IN TAXES CULTURALLY
AFFIRMING THEREBY HELPING
SUPPORT SOCIAL EMOTIONAL WELL
BEING WHICH IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT AT A TIME. WHEN
MULTIPLE WENT ON MENTAL WELLNESS
IS OF CRITICAL CONSIDERATION.
WE'RE ENCOURAGED BY THE
INVESTMENT IN A MULTI LINGUAL
AND CULTURALLY RELEVANT SCHOOL
AND CLASSROOM LIBRARIES PROPOSED
BY THE ADMINISTRATION. I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME AND OUR
DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT SARAH
NOBLE MORGAN THIS YEAR IN CASE
YOU HAVE QUESTIONS RELATED TO
EARLY IDENTIFICATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT
COMPLETES THE PANEL WILL MOVE TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS
FROM. COMMITTEE MEMBERS I JUST
HAD A COMMENT AND THAT IS TO SAY
I FOCUS ON THE- YEAH GO AHEAD OF
THAT AND IT'S JUST TO SAY THAT I
FULLY SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL AND
THAT I PLUG THE GOVERNOR AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOR-
PUSHING THESE PARTIES FORWARD IT
IS IMPORTANT FOR. AS WAS STATED
FOR KIDS. TO SEE REPRESENTATION
THEMSELVES THAT TO ACCOUNT FOR
THE FACT THAT WE DO HAVE SUCH A
DIVERSE POPULATION IN THIS.
STATE AND A TIME WHEN THERE IS A
LOT OF RACIAL ANIMOSITY ARISING-
I THINK IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE-
YOU KNOW THROUGH THROUGH NOT
JUST OUR OUR WORDS BUT ALSO IS
THERE ARE ACTIONS MAKE PEOPLE
RECOGNIZE THAT WE DO WELCOME
THIS DIVERSITY. THANK YOU SANDRA
TROUBLED. YES SO- FIRST OF ALL
AS A FORMER ENGLISH LANGUAGE.
LEARNER TEACHER I COMMEND THE
MERITS AND I DO NOT QUESTION AT
ALL THE MERIT- WHATSOEVER I
THINK IT'S- WE ALL UNDERSTAND
THE IMPORTANCE OF LITERACY AND-
SPECIALLY- AS YOU'RE LEARNING A
SECOND LANGUAGE. RIGHT TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU WILL CONTINUE THE
GROWTH- IN YOUR PRIMARY LANGUAGE
AS FAR AS VOCABULARY GOES AND
CONCEPT ART AND SO FORTH SO.
ABSOLUTELY IN IN IN SUPPORT OF
AB. THE IMPORTANCE OF HAVING-
BOOKS THAT REFLECT OUR OUR
LANGUAGE OUR PARTY LEADERS AS WE
LEARN ENGLISH- I DO HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS WITH REGARDS
TO- THE CURRENT FUNDING THAT WE
HAVE RIGHT NOW THAT'S BEEN
ALLOCATED. ARE INCREASE FUNDING
THAT OUR. SCHOOLS ARE RECEIVING-
AND- V. MY THAT GO- THROUGH THE
L. C. F. AS IN- CATEGORICAL
MONIES THAT GO FOR. CHILDREN AND
SO FORTH HOW DOES THAT SHOULDN'T
THE MONIES THAT OUR CHILDREN ARE
DEPLETED CHILDREN ALREADY
RECEIVE THE COVERING THE SORT OF
MATERIALS FOR OUR OUR ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS SINCE THEY'RE
THE ONES THAT ARE. THE
CIVICALLY- ADDRESSED IN OUR
UNDUPLICATED STUDENTS. CHAU
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- I THINK
THAT I WOULD I WOULD I WOULD
JUST FOR CHIU CD E. A. R. YOU
KNOW MORE SPECIFICS- AS TO- YOU
KNOW HOW HOW. THESE THESE THESE
NEEDS ARE BEING ARE BEING
COVERED BY YOU KNOW OTHER
SOURCES OF FUNDING- I WOULD
PROBABLY JUST NO GENERALLY- YES
PROPOSALS MEANT TO TARGET SOME
OF THE HIGHEST NEEDS SCHOOLS
HIGHER LEVELS OF ENGLISH
LEARNERS- AND YOU HAVE A- OF
FUNDS FOR THESE SPECIFIC
CHILDREN ALREADY. IN OUR FUNDING
FORMULA I MEAN THAT'S WHY WE
HAVE. FUNDING SPECIFICALLY FOR
UNDUPLICATED STUDENTS WHICH ARE
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS
SHOULDN'T THAT FUNDING BE
UTILIZED FOR- BUYING MATERIALS
AND RESOURCES FOR OUR CHILDREN
ARE LEARNING ENGLISH I MEAN WE
ALREADY THAT SPECIFICALLY. AT
THE TOP OF FUNDING THAT WE'VE
BEEN PROVIDING SO FORTH AND I'M
JUST I'M SAYING THIS BECAUSE
WE'RE WE'VE WE'VE ALLOCATED A
LOT OF FUNDING THIS PAST YEAR
AND WE'RE CONTINUING TO DO THAT
AND SO I'M JUST KIND OF CURIOUS
AS TO. WHY AN ADDITIONAL FUNDING
IT'S ONE OF THOSE THINGS THAT-
BUT WE SHOULD ALREADY BE DOING
WITHIN THE CAPACITY OF OUR THE
FUNDING THEY WERE ALREADY IN
PLACE SO I'M JUST KIND OF
CURIOUS AS TO. WHY DO WE HAVE AN
ADDITIONALLY SHOULD WE ALREADY
BE DOING THIS. WITH THE FUNDS
ARE BEING ALLOCATED. ALICIA MORE
IN OUR MARRIAGE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION I WILL
SAY THAT THAT IS ABSOLUTELY
ASPIRATIONAL I'M A ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT I BELIEVE
SCHOOLS FACE WHEN IT COMES TO
DISTRIBUTING FUNDING. IS IN PART
WHEN THEY ARE CONSIDERING
THINKING ABOUT- FUNDING FOR
ENGLISH LEARNER SPECIFICALLY
OFTENTIMES THEY DIFFER TO
ENGLISH LANGUAGE MATERIALS-
WHERE AS THIS PARTICULAR EFFORT
IS CONCENTRATED ON IT DO WHAT
LANGUAGE ARE MULTI LINGUAL
MATERIALS THAT ARE INTENDED TO
BENEFIT ALL LEARNERS IN
CALIFORNIA CLASSROOMS.
PARTICULARLY IN DUAL LANGUAGE
PROGRAMS. OKAY THAT'S MUCH MORE
HELPFUL THAT CLARIFICATION RIGHT
THERE WOULD BE MORE HELPFUL
BECAUSE- AND IT'S INTERESTING
BECAUSE I DO HAVE TO SAY THAT. I
WOULD BE VERY VERY HIGH
DISAPPOINTED TO HEAR THAT ARE
FUNDING FOR OUR UNDUPLICATED
CHILDREN SPECIFICALLY ARE
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS WOULD
NOT BE RECEIVING MATERIALS BOTH
TO LEARN ENGLISH AND TO ALSO
SUPPORT THEIR PRIMARY LANGUAGE
IN THE CLASSROOM AS A FORMER
TEACHER FOR THESE CHILDREN I HAD
YOU KNOW I HAD BOTH ENGLISH AND
I MADE SURE THAT I. I YOU KNOW
FACILITATED BOOKS FOR BOTH IN
BOTH LANGUAGES TO SUPPORT THEIR
LEARNING PROCESS ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY I'VE BEEN ALWAYS AN
ADVOCATE OF MAKING SURE THAT- I
HAVE BEEN OPENLY AN ADVOCATE OF-
TEACHING CHILDREN IN THEIR
PRIMARY LANGUAGE- THE COR
CONTENT COR- DISCOUNTED WHILE
THEY LEARN ENGLISH SO THAT THEY
DON'T FALL BEHIND ACADEMICALLY.
SO JUST WENT OUT AND THEN LAST
QUESTION HERE- IF THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE HAS A COMMENT ON THE
L. A. O.'S RECOMMENDATION TO
REJECT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL AFTER THE ONE TIME FOR
A PROGRAM- THAT WE HAVE A
LIMITED IMPACT THEIR DISAGREED.
YES THEY DO. AND I JUST WANT TO
I JUST WANNA HEAR THEIR THOUGHTS
ON. SURE SO I THINK AS I HAVE
BEEN NOTED EARLIER THIS PROPOSAL
REYES MEANT TO TARGET HIS NEW
SCHOOLS WITH HIGH LEVELS OF
ENGLISH LEARNERS- I THINK I
MIGHT CALL YOU IT SEES OF THE
SIX POINTED AT US. A LOT OF-
GOOD READ. AS TO. THE ETHICS OF
THIS FUND- AND THE WAY THAT I
CAN IMPACT AREAS ACADEMIC
OUTCOMES I THINK WE'VE ALSO
SEEN- SOME RESEARCH SHOWING THAT
YOU KNOW STUDENTS LIVING IN
POVERTY- WORKING FOR STUDENTS OF
COLOR SHOW THE GREATEST GAINS
AND LITERACY- FOREMAN'S ON
STANDARDIZED TESTS. WHEN THEY
HAVE ACCESS. TO STRONG LIBRARY
PROGRAMS- I THINK ALSO GIVEN
THAT- YES UNDERSTANDING THAT
IT'S BEEN OVER. TWO YEARS SINCE
THE STATE HAS REALLY FOCUSED
RESOURCES ON UPDATING SCHOOL
LIBRARIES- WE DO BELIEVE IT IS
IMPORTANT TO. PROVIDE THESE
RESOURCES TO ENSURE- IT YET HIS
MATERIALS ARE CONTENT IN AGE
APPROPRIATE AS WELL AS-
CULTURALLY RELEVANT. DEVELOPMENT
STUDENTS HOME LANGUAGE. WELL
THANK YOU I JUST WANNA JUST JUST
AND MY COMMENTS WITH THE FACT
THAT IF OUR SCHOOLS. ARE NOT
UTILIZING FUNDING TO SUPPORT
LITERACY PROGRAMS THAT COME
SPECIFICALLY BASED ON OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT WE NEED TO
WHAT TYPEOF CLUSTER AS WE NEED
TO CREATE TO SUPPORT OUR ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS AND THAT MEANS
HAVING- BOOKS IN THEIR PRIMARY
LANGUAGE WITH THE EXTRA FUNDING
THAT WE ALREADY PROVIDE. THERE
ARE HAVE ALREADY BEEN IN PLACE
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND ELEVEN
THIRTEENTH I BELIEVE WHEN THERE
WAS A- THAT THE FORMULA- WAS
REVISED I'M SORRY WAS REVISED
REVISED- THEN WE'RE IN WE ARE IN
TROUBLE AND I WOULD HIGHLY
RECOMMEND THAT WE- ARE LOCAL-
EDUCATIONAL. AGENCIES DEFINITELY
LOOK INTO MAKING SURE THAT WE DO
BECAUSE I. MY SPEAR MY SPACE- IN
IN WOULD HAVE IN THE SCHOOL TO
PROVIDE A WORKING WITH. THEY'VE
BEEN VERY VERY SUCCESSFUL IN
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE THOSE
MULTI LINGUAL OF BOOKS IN THE
CLASSROOM AS OUR CHILDREN BUT
I'VE JUST WANTED. WANTED TO KNOW
THAT FOR THE RECORD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE A AND LET ME PRICA
APPRECIATE TO THIS DISCUSSION
MAKE A CLOSING COMMENT AND I WAS
MAKING A- A SNARKY OFF THE MY
COMMENT. WITH REGARD TO THE
QUESTION. OF FINANCES TO WHETHER
THEY AGREED WITH THE L. A. WE-
ADVISING US TO REJECT THE-
RECOMMENDATION THAT I WAS SURE
THEY DISAGREED ARM. BUT I THINK
THA. THIS DISCUSSION HAS BEEN
REALLY ILLUSTRATIVE. BECAUSE I
THINK CENTER MAN ARTICULATELY.
OUTLINED THE NEED FOR THIS AND
THEN TO WHAT IT WORKS AGAINST
AND I THINK SENATOR OCHO BOGUE.
AGREED BUT JUST SAID IS THIS THE
APPROPRIATE FUNDING SOURCE FROM
OTHER OTHER PLACES TO DO IT. AND
WAIT FOR A WAY. HAD THE BENEFIT
OF THE ALEJO'S RECOMMENDATION
WHICH IS GOING TO BE RELEASED
LATER TODAY BUT HAVE THE
DISCUSSION WITHOUT BEING ABLE TO
SEE THE FULL REPORT AND TAKING A
LOOK AT IT. AND SO I THINK THE
NET RESULT OF ALL THIS IS. IS
THAT OF THE COMMITTEE SEEMS TO
HAVE A STRONG CONSENSUS THAT WE
WANT THIS BUT WE THINK OVER THE
NEXT MONTHS THE DISCUSSION
SHOULD BE. ABOUT WHAT'S THE
APPROPRIATE SOURCE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE THIS AND I THINK
THAT'S THE DISCUSSION THAT CAME
OUT WITH TODAY'S. SUBCOMMITTEE
SO THAT THANK YOU FOR ON PANEL
FOR ISSUE THREE. AND WE WILL
MOVE TO ISSUE. THE FREMONT
HOUSING MODERNIZATION PROJECT.
OR OUR PANELISTS RANDALL CAPS
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AMY LEE FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. AND SHALL
COTTON FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WILL TAKE THEM IN THAT
ORDER AND WE'LL START WITH
MISTER KATZ WELCOME TO. THE SUB
COMMITTEE. HELLO ARE CHAIR AND
CALL CENTERS. OUR FINANCE- AND-
I'M THE CAPITAL OUTLAY ANALYSTS
. SO RIGHT NOW- THE ITEM IS THE
STUDENT HOUSING THE- WITH THE
STUDENT HOUSING THE PROJECT IS
PROGRESSING IS REMARKABLE THOSE
WHO FOR THE SCHOOL FOR THE BLIND
AND SCHOOL FROM THE DROP. THE
PROJECT GOING TO WORK THERE
LANDS AND NATURAL EIGHT. HOLES
ON THE GROUND BUT SHOULD.
WORKING DRAWINGS JUST NOT STREET
SIGN. AND FOR THAT IS- LIGHTLY
PRESENTATION AND YOU'LL BE READY
FOR QUITE AND WE GET THINGS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AMY LEE
FROM THE L. A. L. THANK YOU
IMMEDIATELY FROM THE ALLEY-
AGAIN WE DO NOT HAVE A SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATION ON THIS PROPOSAL
WE DO YOU KNOW THAT THEIR TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET INCLUDED
EIGHT POINT FIVE MILLION FOR THE
EARLIER PHASES OF THIS PROJECT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IS IN
LINE WITH THE NEXT PHASE OF THIS
PROJECT TO DEVELOP WORKING
DRAWINGS AND WE BELIEVE THE
TOTAL PROJECT COSTS WERE
ESTIMATED TO BE AROUND. ONE
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS WHICH INCLUDES
INSTRUCTION THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISS COTTON FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CHERYL
COTTON DEBBIE SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT EDUCATION
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY BERMAN THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
ABOUT OUR PROJECT TO MODERNIZE
THE STUDENT HOUSING BUILDINGS
FOR BOTH THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
FOR THE DEAF AND FREMONT. AND
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL FOR THE
BOTTOM LINE BOTH LOCATED IN
FREMONT MODERNIZATION OF THE
FORTY TWO YEAR STUDENT
RESIDENTIAL HOUSING BUILDINGS
WILL OCCUR AT EIGHTEEN HOUSING
BUILDINGS AT THE STX AND EIGHT
HOUSING BUILDINGS AT THE SB
MODERNIZATION FUTILE TO
UTILITIES INFRASTRUCTURE- PATH
OF TRAVEL ROUTES AND COMPLIANCE
WITH THE AMERICANS WITH
DISABILITIES. ACT IS INCLUDED.
WEST SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR TO COME THE WORK DRAWINGS
AS- TOTAL PROJECT ARE ESTIMATED
AT ONE HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN
MILLION EIGHT HUNDRED SIX
THOUSAND. STUDENT HOUSING DESIGN
WILL TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE
UNIQUE NEEDS OF BLIND AND DEAF
STUDENTS BEING EDUCATED AT THE
FREMONT CAMPUS FOR EXAMPLE THE
MODERNIZATION OF THE SCHOOL FOR
THE DEAF MUST CONSIDER EYE
CONTACT TOUCH PHYSICAL PROXIMITY
AND DIRECTNESS. THIS
MODERNIZATION PROJECT WILL
PROVIDE MORE OPEN AREAS FOR SIGN
LANGUAGE ELIMINATES SHARP ANGLES
FROM TROOPS SIDELINES AND
REMOVED HARSH FOR INADEQUATE
LIGHTING. WHEN DESIGNING FOR THE
BLIND OR VISUALLY IMPAIRED
ELEMENTS TO IMPROVE
ACCESSIBILITY OF KEY IMPORTANCE
WERE INCORPORATING VARIOUS TYPES
OF FLOORING AND SIDEWALK
TEXTURES TO PROVIDE WAY.
LANDMARKS DISTINCTIVE FACADES TO
HELP CLEARLY DISTINGUISH BETWEEN
VARIOUS BUILDING LOCATIONS. AND
FOUND INCLUDED SHORE LINING FOR
STUDENTS WITH THIS WITHOUT
VISUAL CUES. DESIGN IS EXPECTED
TO BE COMPLETED BY LATE TWENTY
TWENTY THREE CONSTRUCTION IS
ESTIMATED AT THIRTY SIX MONTH.
IS STUDENT HOUSING MODERNIZATION
PROJECT IS NEEDED TO COMPLY WITH
CURRENT ACCESSIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS AND CODES. IMPROVE
THE AGING UTILITIES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE PROVIDE ENERGY
EFFICIENCY AND PROVIDE SUITABLE
HOUSING NEEDS FOR BOTH BLIND AND
DEAF STUDENTS RESIDING ON THE
FREMONT CAMPUS. I'M AVAILABLE AS
WELL AS JENNIFER MALCOLM
DEPARTMENTAL CONSTRUCTION AND
MAINTENANCE SUPERVISOR FOR THE
STATE SPECIAL SCHOOLS AND
SERVICES DIVISION THE ANSWER ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS. YOU HAVE AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU
VERY WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
PRESENTATION AND MAYBE LET ME
MAKE A BRIEF STATEMENT. AND THEN
ASK A QUESTION THAT IS PROBABLY
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
BUT ARM WE HAVE I THINK THREE
OUR SCHOOLS IN THE STATE THE
DOOR SPECIAL SCHOOLS DIAGNOSTIC
CENTERS OF. AND THEY ARE LISTED
IN OUR AGENDA PACKET AND WHAT'S
INTERESTING IS THEY DON'T
USUALLY COME IN FRONT OF THIS-
COMMITTEE THEY'RE USUALLY VERY
DEEPLY IN THE BUDGET AND- JUST
RENEWED EVERY YEAR. AND EXCEPT
FOR OUR ITEMS LIKE THIS WE
WOULDN'T TALK ABOUT THEM AND I
ASKED THAT IT BE ELEVATED FOR
DISCUSSION SO THAT WE ACTUALLY
HAVE IN OUR CHEN. OF THE SCHOOLS
IN A RELATIVE THING AND WE HAD A
VERY HEARTWARMING STORY ABOUT
THE SUCCESSFUL SPORTS TEAM OUT
OF RIVERSIDE FROM ONE OF THE
SCHOOLS. ARE THAT REALLY SHOWS
THAT THEY'RE JUST A VITAL PART
OF OUR- OF OUR LIFE AND OUR
EDUCATIONAL CULTURE. AND SO I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
HAVE OUR EYES ON IT JUST TO MAKE
SURE THAT. THE TERROR ADEQUATELY
FUNDED AND ADEQUATELY RESOURCE
AND THAT WE HAVE SOME MEASURE OF
OVERSIGHT OVER THE SUCCESS OF
THESE INSTITUTIONS. AND SO THAT
IS THE REASON IT'S HERE EVEN
THOUGH IT MIGHT SEEM LIKE IT'S
AN OBSCURE. ARE- ITEM IN IT A.
N. G. THIS IS SOMETIMES THE
ITEMS SUCH AS THE ONE IN FRONT
OF US. ON THE MODERNIZATION
PROJECT ON CAPITAL IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAMS AND YOU CAN'T TELL IF
THEY'RE GOING TO BE REACHED A
WORK. OR IF THEY GET THERE BUT I
THINK THIS IS OUR STATEMENT OF
SAYING THAT THEY'RE VERY
IMPORTANT AND WE HOPE THAT THEY
ARE REACHED AND WE- WE HOPE THAT
THAT THAT THERE IS DISCUSSION IT
IS A PRIORITY FOR THE
INSTITUTIONS OF STATE GOVERNMENT
THAT WOULD DEAL WITH THIS. MY
ONE QUESTION IS PROBABLY FOR THE
- DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. IS
REALLY WHAT RESOURCES ARE
AVAILABLE TO THE STATE SPECIAL
SCHOOLS FOR EXTRACURRICULAR
ACTIVITIES IS THERE ARE COMMON
FUND. THEY CAN TAP INTO FOR
SPORTS OR OTHER EXTRACURRICULAR
ACTIVITIES BECAUSE- IT SEEMS
LIKE IMPROVEMENTS FOR SOME OF
THE SPORTS FACILITIES. THAT WERE
JUST HIGHLIGHTED AND SEEM TO BE
SUCH. A OF ALL LWER- JUST OF
OUR LAST IMPROVED SPORTS
FACILITIES AND WE HAVE FOR OTHER
SIMILAR EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS
SO QUESTIONS WHAT RESOURCES ARE
AVAILABLE TO THE STATE. A
SPECIAL SCHOOLS FOR
EXTRACURRICULAR ACTIVITIES AND I
THINK THAT SHOULD GO TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. SO
THERE IS NO LINE ITEM AT THIS
POINT BUT I DO WANT TO STATE
THAT LIKE MILLIONS OF OTHER
CALIFORNIANS THE GOVERNOR WAS
INSPIRED BY THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL FOR THE DEAF RIVERSIDE'S
FOOTBALL TEAM SUCCESS LAST
SEASON- THE PROJECT TO UPGRADE.
THE CST OUR SPORTS FIELD AND
BLEACHERS WILL BE UNDER
CONSIDERATION THIS SPRING ONCE
THE PROJECT SCOPE INCLUDING
SWING SPACE FOR THE TEAMS AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES AS WELL AS MANY
FAMILIES. SO THAT IS I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU SHOULD HAVE USED THE
PHRASE WING SPACE TO THE
LEGISLATURE THAT MIGHT. THAT
MIGHT NOT MAKERS OF JUMPED
IMMEDIATELY IN SUPPORT- BUT DO
YOU THINK THAT THAT INFORMATION
WILL BE READY IN TIME TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE THIS CONSIDERED AS PART
OF. A MAY. BUDGET WE'RE HOPEFUL
. OKAY WHILE I WOULD JUST SAY I
APPRECIATE THE HOPE I APPRECIATE
THE FAITH WAS JUST TRYING TO
MAKE THAT INFORMATION HAPPENED
SO THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY HAVE THE
DISCUSSION IN THE ARMY. AND I
THANK YOU FOR THE BACKGROUND ON
THIS LET ME ASK MY COLLEAGUES IF
THERE ANY QUESTIONS BEFORE WE
MOVE ON. SEEING NONE. A BAR I
JUST APPRECIATE THAT DISCUSSION.
AND WE WILL MOVE TO ISSUE NUMBER
FIVE THE SCHOOL FACILITY
PROGRAM. AND WE HAVE JENNIFER
KACU AND I APOLOGIZE IF I
MISPRONOUNCE YOUR NAME FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AMY LEE
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. AND LISA SILVERMAN FROM
THE OFFICE OF PUBLIC SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF GENERAL SERVICES. AND WE WILL
GO IN THAT ORDER- FINANCE
WELCOME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
HI AND MY APOLOGIES ON JENNER
JENNIFER **** WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOR SOME
REASON MY CAMERA. FAILING TO
TURN ON AT THE MOMENT SO I'LL
JUST CONTINUE WITH MY
PRESENTATION IF THAT'S ALRIGHT
OKAY YOU DON'T HAVE A CANDLE
BURKE AND BURNING IN THE
BACKGROUND TO. UNFORTUNATELY I
DO NOT BUT I. JUST FIND THE
MOMENT. OKAY COMMITTEE THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING JERRY MEMBERS
JENNIFER **** WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE SCHOOL
FACILITIES AID PROGRAM PROVIDES
FUNDING FOR LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES FOR K. TO TWELVE SCHOOL
FACILITIES SUCH AS SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION MODERNIZATION AND
EMERGENCY REPAIRS THIS PROGRAM
IS ADMINISTERED BY THE STATE
LOCATION BOARD WHICH IS STOP BY
THE OFFICE PUBLIC SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. FOUR BILLION DOLLARS TO
SUPPORT SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION
BECAUSE PROPOSITION FIFTY ONE
BOND AUTHORITY IS EXPECTED TO BE
EXHAUSTED IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE IN THE BUDGET
PROPOSES ONE POINT TWO FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME GENERAL
SIGN IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
AND NINE HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR TO
SUPPORT NEW CONSTRUCTION AND
MODERNIZATION PROJECTS THROUGH
THE SCHOOL FACILITY PROGRAM.
I'LL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS
TALK TO OUR NEXT WILL HAVE- AMY
LEAP FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST OFFICE. THANK YOU NEARLY
FROM LA- AGAIN WE DO NOT HAVE A
SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATION ON THE
GOVERNOR'S CALLS ON SCHOOL
FACILITIES PROGRAM AND BUT WE
DID WANT TO NOTE SEVERAL THINGS
IN ADDITION TO THE POINT THAT
FINANCE SHARED. SO OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT- PSC HAS A
WAIT LIST OF NEW CONSTRUCTION
AND MODERNIZATION PROJECTS THAT
TOTALS AROUND THREE BILLION
DOLLARS BEYOND BOND AUTHORITY
THE PROPOSED FUNDING FOR TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE AND TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR WHAT FRONT
AROUND THREE FOURTHS OF THE WAIT
LIST OF PROJECTS BUT THAT IS
JUST A POINT IN TIME ESTIMATE.
WE NOTICED THAT THE FUNDING
SCHOOL FACILITIES PROJECTS USE
USING WE KNOW THAT USING-
SCHOOL. FUNDING SCHOOL
FACILITIES PROJECTS USING
GENERAL FUND WILL LIKELY BE LESS
COSTLY THAN USING GENERAL
OBLIGATION FUNDS DUE TO STATE
SAVINGS ON INTEREST COSTS LASTLY
AS MENTIONED IN YOUR AGENDA
EARLIER IN THE HEARING IN THE
STATE IS ABOVE ITS STATE
APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT FOR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. AND TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO ON THE PROPOSED
FUNDING FOR SCHOOL FACILITIES
PROGRAMS WOULD BE CONSIDERED
EXCLUDABLE FROM THE PROVISIONS
LIMIT- HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND WE'LL MOVE. TO THE
THIRD PANELIST. HI GOOD MORNING
THAT MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
AND CHAIRMAN I'M LISA SILVERMAN
AND EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
OFFICE OF PUBLIC SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION IN THE STATE
LOCATION BOARD AND I'M HERE WITH
MY COLLEAGUE BARBARA CAN'T MINOR
CHOOSE A DEPUTY EXACTLY
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
ORGANIZATION. AND THE OFFICE OF
PUBLIC SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION
SERVES AS YOU HEARD ALREADY SAY
I CATION BOARD AND WE ADMINISTER
THE FORTY TWO BILLION DOLLARS
SCHOOL FACILITIES BOND PROGRAM
ON BEHALF BUDGET DEPARTMENT
GENERAL SERVICES. THE SCHOOL
FACILITY PER IS A PER WITH THIS
PARTY WITH LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES IN ORDER TO FIND THEIR
SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS.
THIS PROGRAM HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL
OVER THE YEARS. AND AS A RESULT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY- AND HOW THEY USE
OUR FUNDS AND IT'S BASED ON
THEIR LOCAL PRIORITIES. SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT. FORTY TWO
BILLION DOLLARS HAVE BEEN-
AUTHORIZED BY VOTERS FOR THE
SCHOOL FACILITIES PROGRAM. AND
TO THAT EXTENT WE HAVEAWARDED
OVER THIRTY NINE BILLION DOLLARS
TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS STATEWIDE.
AND THROUGH THE OUTCOMES OF THE
PROGRAM WE WANTED TO SHARE THAT
NEARLY TWENTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS HAVE BEEN AWARDED FOR
NEW CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS AND
THAT REPRESENTS FORTY THREE
HUNDRED- PROJECTS AWARDED. AND
THAT REPRESENTS FIFTY EIGHT
THOUSAND YOU CLASSROOMS
CONSTRUCTED. THERE HAVE BEEN
NEARLY FOURTEEN BILLION DOLLARS
ALSO AWARDED FOR THE
MODERNIZATION PROGRAM. AND THAT
REPRESENTS OVER SEVENTY SEVEN
HUNDRED PROJECTS. AND MODERNIZE
IN OVER A HUNDRED FORTY FOUR
THOUSAND CLASSROOMS. AND IN THE
KERR TECH EDUCATION PROGRAM THIS
PROGRAM HAS AWARDED OVER EIGHT
HUNDRED FIFTY NINE PROJECTS- SO
FOUR NINE HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR
MILLION. AND FOR THE CHARTER
SCHOOL FACILITY PROGRAM WE'VE
AWARDED OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
EIGHTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
EIGHTY TWO PROJECTS. YOU KNOW
THE OFFICE OF PUBLIC SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION ALSO HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY AND HAS ALL THE
OPPORTUNITY TO AWARD A PROGRAM
FUNDS. TO THE FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN BROWN AS A RESULT
OF THE- EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET
AND SO WE WERE ALLOCATED A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AND WE
HAVE AWARDED THIS PROJECTS- IN%
MAY AND OCTOBER OF TWENTY
NINETEEN AND THAT REPRESENTS
FORTY SEVEN PROJECTS AND AGAIN
THAT'S A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
HAVE GONE OUT- WE ACTUALLY HAD.
A GREAT OPPORTUNITY IN THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET
YEAR. AND WE'VE EXPANDED THE
PROGRAM TO INCLUDE CALIFORNIA
PRESCHOOL AND TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTENERS. IN THIS NEW
PROGRAM AS A WE HAVE A FOUR
HUNDRED NINETY MILLION DOLLARS
THAT WE WOULD GET ON THE BOARD
HAS SET TO ALLOCATE. TWO FUNDING
ROUNDS AT ONE BEGINNING IN APRIL
OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO. FOUR TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE SECOND PROGRAM-
AWARDS BEGAN. ACCEPTING
APPLICATIONS ON APRIL FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND THAT'S A
REMAINING BALANCE OF THE PROGRAM
FUNDS. AND TO THAT EXTENT I
WANTED TO SHARE AND AS YOU KNOW
THERE WE HAVE TO EXISTING LIST-
THAT REPRESENTS PART OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WE HAVE A-
LIST THAT WE TAKE IN PROJECTS-
BASICALLY. IN THE CURRENT BONTA
STORY. AND THOSE APPLICATIONS
ARE REVIEWED AND PRESENTED TO
THE BOARD- AND AGAIN THEY HAVE
BONTA STORY SET ASIDE FOR THESE
PROJECTS AND. ARE PRESENTED AND
I'M FUNDS APPROVAL- ASK MOVE
THROUGH THE PROCESS- THESE
PROJECTS PRISON LATER ON- AS A
RESULT THE- SALE. IN THE- AT
TIME TO JUST CAN'T. CASH THEIR
PROJECTS. AND AGAIN IT'S BASED
ON CONTINGENT ON A BOND SALE BE
DEFERRED. ANTIBIOTICS WE HAVE
SINCE JANUARY THIRTY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO WE HAVE A
HUNDRED SIXTY THREE PROJECTS
THAT ARE WAITING FOR BOND SALES.
AND THAT REPRESENTS. FOUR
HUNDRED SIXTY THREE THREE
MILLION DOLLARS. AND AS THEY
SHARED EARLIER- MY COLLEAGUES
FROM AND LEO- WE HAVE
APPLICATIONS RECEIVED BONTA AND
BEYOND BONTA THIRTY LIST. AND
AGAIN WE RECEIVE THESE
APPLICATIONS- BASED ON THEIR
ABILITY TO HAVE A DEPARTMENTS
CATION APPROVAL DIVISIONS
ARCHITECTURE APPROVAL. AND THEY
CAN REQUEST- STATE FUNDS
UNFORTUNATELY WE DON'T HAVE
BONTA THIRTY TO APPROVE OR EVEN
PROCESSES PROJECTS TO OUR
CURRENT KNOWLEDGE LISTS WE HAVE
OVER THREE POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS AND THAT REPRESENTS NINE
HUNDRED FORTY FOUR PROJECTS. AND
TO THAT EXTENT- I JUST WANT TO
BRIEFLY SHARE- THE PROCESS OF
PRESENTING PROJECTS TO SEE
ALLOCATION BOARD- MAINLY FOR THE
NEW CONSTRUCTION AND
MODERNIZATION PROJECTS. AGAIN
THEY HAVE TO HAVE AN APPROVAL
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
AND THE DIVISION STATE
ACHITECTURE PROVOKING FOR
COMING IN FOR FINDING. OUR
PROGRAM ESTABLISHES WHETHER NOT
THEY MEET THE ELIGIBILITY
COMPONENTS. AND IF THEY DO THE
PROGRAM THE PROJECT CAN ADVANCE
AND ALSO SUBMIT A PLANNING
APPLICATION. AND OTHER STEP IS
THE C. I. CATION BOARD APPROVING
THE PROJECT ONCE STAFF HAVE
REVIEW. REVIEW IS COMPLETED. AND
TO THAT EXTENT- THE CURRENT
PROCESS IS THE ONES OF PROJECTS
HAVE BEEN APPROVED BY ISRAELI
CATION BOARD AND HOW THE
SPAWNING DORIA SITE TO ASSIGN TO
THAT. THEN WE HAVE TO WAIT FOR
CASH AS A RESULT OF THE BOND%
SALE BEFORE WE CAN RELEASE CASH
TUNING TO DISTRICTS FOR THEIR-
PROJECTS. AND TO THAT EXTENT I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER. ANY QUESTIONS
AND THANK YOU FOR THE OPTION
PERCENT. THANK YOU VERY. OF A
COMMENT NINE ONE QUESTION. IN
THE COMMON IS THAT BASED ON. OF
COURSE EVERYWHERE I GO AND WITH
EVERY EDUCATION GROUP THERE'S A
STATEMENT THAT. THAT WE ARE
RUNNING OUT OF MONEY AND THERE'S
NOT ADEQUATE MONEY FOR
FACILITIES THERE'S A REAL NEED
ACROSS THE STATE AND- IN THE
STAFF REPORT IT CORROBORATED BY
THE TESTIMONY HERE IT WAS
REALLY. ONE POINT FOUR BILLION
AS THE LAST OF WHAT EXISTS IN
AND BOND MONEY THAT IS ALREADY.
APPROPRIATED AND THEN TWO POINT
TWO BILLION THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
RECOMMENDING OVER THE NEXT TWO
BUDGET YEARS- AS THE NEXT STEP
FOR THAT TO TRY TO TAKE THE
FACILITY SAYS THE COMMON USE
THAT. OUR OUR MONEY FROM THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET TO DO IT. THEN LET
ME ASK FINANCE FROM. THE
IMPLICATION IS AND I THINK
SOMEBODY EVEN USED THE WORD.
THAT THIS IS A BRIDGE A BRIDGE
TO SOME FUTURE FUNDING SOURCE
DECEIT MINISTRATION HAVE A
POSITION ON THE NEXT FUNDING
SOURCE. WHAT IT MIGHT BE IF WE
APPROVE THE SAID AND HOW WE
WOULD GO FORWARD AFTER THE. HI
JENNIFER CALL TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE- AT THIS TIME WE'RE
NOT PROPOSING ON ANY SORT OF
BOND BILL OUR FUTURE BOND
LEGISLATION- BUT WE'RE HAPPY TO
CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS INTO THE
FUTURE. K. PROP. WHENEVER
FINANCES THEY'RE HAPPY TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS I GUESS YOU HAVE
TO RUN WITH IT. THEM BUT LET ME
JUST SAY THAT. THE HEAD OF THE
STAFF REPORT AND THE FACT THAT
THE GOVERNOR'S AS HAVING TO
RECOMMEND TWO POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS. TO MEET THE NEED IN THE
AND THE NEXT PERIOD OF TIME
MAKES THE CASE. FOR SOME LONG
TERM FUNDING STRUCTURE TO DEAL
WITH FACILITIES IN THE SCHOOLS
AND SO. ON EVEN THOUGH YOU'RE
WILLING TO JUST HAVE
CONVERSATIONS AND NOT TAKE
POSITION I HOPE THAT MEANS THAT
SUBJECT OF THE CONVERSATION IS
HOW TO MEET THIS NEED GOING
FORWARD. SO LET ME ASK- MY
COLLEAGUES IF THERE ANY
QUESTIONS. ARE THERE NO
QUESTIONS SO- WHAT'S THANK THE
PANELISTS FOR- OF PARTICIPATING
IN ITEM NUMBER SIX. AND WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE TO- ISSUE NUMBER I
MEAN FIVE MOVED TO ISSUE NUMBER
SIX. THE CHARTER SCHOOL FACILITY
GRANT PROGRAM. AND WILL HAVE A
GOOD. DAY JENNIFER KACU AGAIN
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
EDGAR CABRAL FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
KATRINA JOE HAND CHEN. FROM THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL FINANCE
AUTHORITY WE WILL TAKE THEM AND
AFTER. HELLO FONG WELCOME BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE. HELLO AGAIN
CHAIRED MEMBERS JENNIFER
CROCKETT WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
FINANCE AUTHORITY PROVIDES
FACILITIES IN WORKING CAPITAL
FINANCING TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION AND
CHARTER SCHOOLS- MORE
SPECIFICALLY THE CHARTER SCHOOL
FACILITY GRANT PROGRAM PROVIDES
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND GRANTS TO ASSIST CHARTER
SCHOOLS. AND LEAST COST THIS
PROGRAM TARGET SCHOOL AND
COMMUNITIES WITH SIGNIFICANT
POPULATIONS OF ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES AN
INCREASE OF THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS ON GOING PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT OTHER ELIGIBLE
FACILITIES COST FOR THE CHARTER
SCHOOL FACILITY GRANT PROGRAM
ADDITIONALLY- THIS PROGRAM
RECEIVED TWO POINT NINE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR A COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT AND SIX MILLION
DOLLARS FOR A CURRENT SERVICE
LEVEL ADJUSTMENT. I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL MOVE TO THE OHIO.
MORNING RODILLAS ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND WE DON'T HAVE ANY
CONCERNS WITH THE PAST THE
PROPOSAL. IN OUR CONVERSATIONS
OF FRAMPTON AND THE FATE OF IF.
BUT THE IS A FOR IN BY. TO SEE
WITH THE PERCENT SO ALREADY
KITCHENS I YOU VERY MUCH AND
THEN WILL MOVE TO THE CALIFORNIA. SCHOOL FINANCE AFFORD. YES
GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE MY AND
CHARLIER- CHANGING HANSHIN THE
CAR SCHOOL. OR THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME THIS MORNING. I'M IS
JENNIFER MENTIONS THE SFA IS
ADMINISTERED THE CHARTER SCHOOL
SO THE GRANT PROGRAM SINCE
TWENTY FOURTEEN. SINCE THAT TIME
WE HAVE SEEN DEMAND FOR THE
PROGRAM GROW AS THE COSTS OF
FACILITIES AND MAINTENANCE OF
SAID FACILITIES THAT HAS
OUTPACED AVAILABLE FUNDING
THROUGH THIS PROGRAM. THE
PROGRAM GIVES PRIORITY TO RUN
LEAST. AND FUNDS ARE AVAILABLE
AFTER BRITAIN'S COST OF PAID
OTHER COST HER FIND IT. THE LAW
STATES THAT THE SONS ALSO MADE
USE FOR COSTS INCLUDING BUT NOT
LIMITED TO COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
REMODELING BUILDINGS DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE. INITIALLY
INSTALLING OR EXTENDING SERVICE
SYSTEMS AND OTHER BUILT IN
EQUIPMENT AND IMPROVING SITES.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN FUNDING
ROUNDS THE LAST TIMES YESTERDAY
WAS ABLE TO FIND OTHER COSTS
UNDER THE PROGRAM. AND DURING
THAT FUNDING ROUND ELIGIBLE
APPLICANTS RECEIVED ONLY 46% OF
ELIGIBLE COSTS UNDER THIS
CATEGORY. THE NEW AN ONGOING
FUNDING AUGMENTATION BEING
PROPOSED BY THE ADMINISTRATION
WILL ENSURE THAT CHARTER SCHOOL
FACILITIES ARE WELL MAINTAINED
AND SAFE FOR STUDENTS. IF THIS
PROPOSAL IS APPROVED IT IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT SCHOOLS
TOTAL AWARDS WILL NEVER EXCEED
THE WAR CAPTIVES FROM AND- BY
EACH SCHOOL'S AVERAGE DAILY
ATTENDANCE AWARD. ADDITIONALLY
IF APPROVED YESTERDAY WILL WORK
TO IMPLEMENT ANY NECESSARY
REGULATORY CHANGES RELATED TO
FUNDING FOR PUBLIC RELATED
MITIGATION PENSION. AS WELL AS
WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO ENSURE THAT THE
AUTHORITY HAS ADEQUATE
RESOURCES. TO CARRY OUT THIS
FUNDING AUGMENTATION. AND
EFFICIENT AND PRUDENT MANNER.
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWERING
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LEMASS MY COLLEAGUES IF THEY
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS THE SUN. GEN
ROADSHOW ABOVE. I JUST WANT TO.
THANK THE CONSIDERATION THAT-
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
HAS PUT IN ALLOCATING FUNDS FOR
CHARTER SCHOOLS I'M JUST
SPEAKING PERSONALLY FROM OUR AT
MY LOCAL EXPERIENCE FOR MY
SCHOOL DISTRICT- IT IS
ABSOLUTELY. IMPERATIVE THAT WE
ACTUALLY PROVIDE SOME FNDING
FOR A LOCAL CHARTER SCHOOLS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE- THEY
HAVE THESE THESE FUNDS SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. FOR REALLOCATION
. WE'RE A YOUR COMMON. AND I
WOULD JUST SAY THIS ITEM SEEMS
FAIRLY SELF EXPLANATORY SO- WITH
CENTER GROVE CHAU BUGS COMMENT
SO LET ME THANK THE PANELISTS.
OF FOR BEING HERE. AND ARE NOW-
HELLO WE WILL MOVE TO PUBLIC
COMMENT WHICH IS ANYBODY THAT
WISHES TO OUR- TO MAKE A PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE SIX ITEMS WE HAVE
DISCUSSED. AS A REMINDER TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBERS.
877-226-8163 THEN THE ACCESS
CODE IS SEVEN THREE SIX TWO
EIGHT THREE THREE. ARM DUE TO A
OF RESTRAINTS ON JUST HEARING
TIME ARMINA LIMIT EACH MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC UP TO ONE MINUTE IN
THEIR COMMENTS TODAY AND IF IT
TURNS OUT THAT. THAT WE HAVE
MANY MANY WHICH I'M NOT SURE
THAT WE WILL OUR MIGHT REVISIT
THAT- GOING INTO IT BECAUSE WE
NEED TO TRY TO BE OUT OF HERE
BY- ABOUT THIRTY FIVE MINUTES
FROM NOW. THEN LET ME ASK FIRST
BEFORE I GO TO THE MODERATOR AND
STAND BY MODERATOR. ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN THE HEARING
WORLD WISH TO WALK COMMENT ON
THE SIDE. EVERYBODY HAS A JOB
DUTY IN THE HEARING ROOM THAT IS
NOT TESTIFYING SO NOBODY IS
MOVING TO THE MICROPHONE. SO
MODERATOR- WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. WAITED TWENTY MINUTES
FOR THE COMING UP WITH. PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE ENTER
ON YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE. REMOVE
YOURSELF AT ANY TIME VERY
PUTTING THE ONE ZERO COMMAND.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO. AND MODERATOR AND
THAT'S JUST WHAT I WAS GOING TO
ASK THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT
USUALLY DOUBLES SO I THINK WE'RE
WITHIN OUR TIME SO A MODERATOR
THANK YOU FOR THAT INTRODUCTION
WELCOME AGAIN TO THE COMMITTEE
AND LET'S BEGIN WITH THE FIRST
CALL. STRUGGLING NUMBER FOURTEEN
YEAR LANCE NOW OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU DOWNLOAD WITH A
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION WE ARE HAPPY TO SEE
THE GOVERNOR CONTINUED
INVESTMENT IN THE UNIVERSAL
BREAKFAST AND LUNCH PROGRAM WE
ARE ALSO HAPPY TO SEE THE ONE IN
HALF BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
IN ELECTRIC THE FACT THAT AND
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
EARLIER ON HOME PEOPLE
TRANSPORTATION. OTHER OPENING
OCTOBER IT'S IMPORTANT WE WANT
TO EMPHASIZE THAT WE STILL HAVE
A LONGSTANDING UNDEFINED THE
PROBLEMS IN OUR CURRENT
POLITICAL TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM
WE NEED A SOLUTION THAT WOULD
SIGNIFICANTLY WORK ON THE
PROGRAM ADEQUATELY FUND STUDENT
TRANSPORTATION. EXACTLY
APPORTIONED FUNDS TO PULL THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUR.
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. PHOTO
ENTERED OR IS OPEN PLEASE GO.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS JOHN LINGER
ON BEHALF OF THE CHAU SCHOOLS
YEAR SPEAKING ISSUE STICK I
WOULD LIKE TO THE GOVERNOR FOR
THE THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSAL TO HELP FULLY FUNDED
CHARTER SCHOOL FACILITY GRANT
PROGRAM. PROGRAM HAS BEEN HIGHLY
SUCCESSFUL IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT FOR OUR SCHOOLS
SERVING MOSTLY UNDERSERVED
STUDENT POPULATIONS
UNFORTUNATELY THE PROGRAM HAS
BEEN CHRONICALLY UNDERFUNDED WE
JUST HAD A VERY REAL IMPACT ON
OUR STUDENTS ON THE PROGRAM FALL
SHORT ALL SCHOOLS GET THEIR
FUNDING CUTS AND WE MUST BE
BURKE. FUNDING FROM OUR CORE
PROGRAMS TO COVER THE SILICON
ACCESS TO ADEQUATE FACILITIES
CONTINUES TO BE A PRIMARY
CHALLENGER TRIP PUBLIC CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND THE CHARTER SCHOOL
FACILITY GRANT PROGRAM HAS BEEN
VITAL IN SUPPORTING PUBLIC
CHARTER SCHOOLS IN HIGH NEED
COMMUNITIES. WE ARE GRATEFUL
THAT GOVERNOR NATION'S PROPOSED
AN INCREASE TO ADDRESS THIS
CHRONIC FUNDING SHORTFALLS IN
THE PROGRAM AND WE HOPE THE
COMMITTEE WILL SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGETPROPOSAL THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS.
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. HELLO SIX.
LANES OF PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU CAN REALLY ROSENBERGER WITH
SEIU I DO HAVE A CANDLE IN THE
BACKGROUND- WE ARE SUPPORTED
THAT ALWAYS HAPPENS WHEN
NOBODY'S ON CAMERA SO OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NO NO NO NO- WE
ARE OF THE INVESTMENT UNIVERSAL
BREAKFAST LUNCH AND IS ALMOST.
IN THE END THAT OFTEN INCLUDE
BRINGING THE WORK FORCE FEED ON
THE TRAINING NEEDED- AND BRING
THEM ALONG THANK YOU TO WORKERS
THE DEDICATED- WE HAVE SUCH A
SHORTAGE I'M WORKFORCE IT OUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS. MODERATOR NEXT CALL.
TOTALING MILLION OF TO GO AHEAD
. GOOD MORNING I TRAILER TO
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE MY
NAME IS JESSICA PSYCHO CALLING
IN ON BEHALF OF CHILDREN NOW. IN
REGARDS TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE
WELL WE SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S COMMITMENT TO
MULTI LINGUAL LIBRARIES AND
EARLY LITERACY WE WOULD LIKE TO
ENSURE THAT THE PROGRAM TO
CREATE MULTI LINGUAL CLASSROOM
LIBRARIESINCLUDE CULTURALLY
COMPETENT AND RELEVANT
LITERATURE TO DEVELOP KNOWLEDGE
AND SKILLS AND BOTH THEIR HOME
LANGUAGE AND ENGLISH WHILE
PROVIDING CORE CONTENT WITH A
FOCUS ON CREATING EQUITY IN
OPPORTUNITIES AND ELIMINATING
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS. FURTHERMORE WE
AGREE WITH THE L. A- THAT DEPEND
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
BILINGUAL TEACHERS IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT IN ADDITION TO
SUPPORTING TEACHERS WITH
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING AND OTHER
TRAINING AND SUPPORT SO THAT IF
THESE INVESTMENTS IN THE
LIBRARIES ARE MADE THEY'RE ABLE
TO SUPPORT THEIR STUDENTS THAT-
BUT CORPORATE LEE AND ACCESSING
AND MAKING BUT THE MOST USE OF
THESE MATERIALS. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS. MODERATOR NEXT CALLER
. ABOUT ELENA NINETEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN GO AHEAD. MORNING MY
NAME IS JENNIFER BAKER I MARK
THE- TO. I AND- PROBABLY. THE
CONVERSATION DEVELOPMENT
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE ALSO SHARE
SOME OF THE ALLEY OWN CONCERNS
SEVERAL PROGRAMS WITHIN THE
ANNEX EDUCATION BUDGET TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE DO NOT HAVE
ADEQUATE RESOURCES TO ACHIEVE
THE STATED GOAL. INCLUDING A
LACK OF TRANSLATION BY LITERACY
SERVICES BUT WE BELIEVE THAT
THERE ARE AN IMPORTANT STEP
FORWARD AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
COMMUNICATING THOSE ISSUES.
RESHAPING THE CRASH YOU JUST
WEAKER THE- THAT. OF THE MORE
LINGUAL LIBRARY. AND WE URGE YOU
TO CONSIDER THAT MULTI LINGUAL
TEXT BOOK BE AVAILABLE IN EIGHT
LANGUAGES OTHER THAN ENGLISH
DIDN'T HIS. PRIMARY HOME
LANGUAGES AND ALSO PROVIDE THE
RESOURCES NECESSARY ALL SCHOOLS
THAT HAVE STUDENTS WHOSE HOME
LANGUAGE IS NOT ENGLISH.
PROFESSIONAL FORWARD WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE THE LACK OF BILINGUAL
TEACHERS NOTED BY THE L. A. L.
COMMENTS AND WE WILL REFLECT ON
THESE TWO KEY NEEDS AND LOOK
FORWARD TO SHARING OUR EXPERTISE
WITH YOU. AT THE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR- A MODERATOR CALL. TOTALING
TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING
THIS IS CHRISTINA COLLECT THAT
WOULD CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER WE
ALIGN WITH- GARBAGE IN CHILDREN
NINE COMMENTED STATED YOU'RE
FREE HEARING YOUR DISCUSSION
TODAY REGARDING THE MULTILINGUAL
COOL. COOL THEN CLASSROOM
LIBRARY GRANT PROGRAMS. THAT
CHILDREN DO NEED BOTH IN THEIR
HOME LANGUAGES WITH REFLECT ON
VIDEOCON AS WELL AS A LAYER YOUR
COMPANY AND LOOK FORWARD TO OUR
- I THE CONGREGATION BALLOT. I
THE PROPOSAL I STAND NOW WOULD
LIKE TO INSURE THE SUN ARE USED
FOR OUR MORE TAKE. AND MULTI CAR
THREE FACTORS THEIR- NOT ONLY AT
THE LEVEL BUT IT SHOULD NONSTICK
JEFF MENTION FEW THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONCERN. THANK VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR MODERATOR CALL. THANKS
FOR THE DELAY IN TWO THE LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE AHEAD. THIS IS KEREN
MAY AND THIS IS TO MARC THE CFT
UNION ANY AND- PERFECT. CST OF
POINT FIVE BILL FOR THE EMISSION
BY FLEET. IF YOU SUPPORT CAN BE
. THAT MOVE US TOWARD CRISTINA
AND CLIMB JEFF WE BELIEVE THAT
THE STATE PUBLIC AND- SHOULD BE
A PLAN. TO REDUCING CARBON
EMISSIONS AND THE STATE THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS A
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. BECHTEL
TWENTY THREE LINE OPEN GO AHEAD. ONE TWENTY THREE WHO LEARNS
OPEN. YOU MAY BE MUTED. A LITTLE
CURRENTL NUMBER ELEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO SENATORS HI MY NAME IS
JONATHAN KLEIN I'M A CALIFORNIAN
DOWN AND THE CO FOUNDER OF
UNCONSCIOUSLY TWELVE I NONPROFIT
WORKING TO SUPPORT SCHOOLS TO
MAKE EQUITABLE TRANSITION. ZERO
EMISSIONS AFTER SEVERAL YEARS OF
DESTRUCTION FROM WILDFIRES AND
HEATWAVES ARE SIX MILLION
STUDENTS AND THEIR PARENTS KNOW
THAT OUR SCHOOL BUILDING ARE NOT
EQUIPPED AND NOT PREPARED FOR
RAPIDLY CHANGING CLIMATE AND
EXTREME WEATHER. I SPEAK TODAY
REGARDING ISSUE FIVE ASK YOU TO
CONSIDER OPPORTUNITIES TO
ADVANCE CLIMATE RESILIENT SCHOOL
BUILDINGS AND GROUNDS WITH IN
THE STATE BUDGET. FIRST I HEARD
YOU ENSURE THAT THE TWO POINT
TWO BILLION PROPOSED FOR SCHOOL
INFRASTRUCTURE ARE INVESTED IN
THE CLEAR STANDARDS FOR
EMISSIONS REDUCTION AND
RESILIENCE TO CLIMATE IMPACT.
SHOULD ADDITIONAL RESOURCES BE
AVAILABLE FOR THE MAINLY BY
INCREASED FUNDING FOR CLIMATE
RESILIENT SCHOOLS WOULD BE AN
EXCELLENT PLACE TO MAKE AN
AUGMENTATION. CAN WE NEED TO
INVEST IN A STATEWIDE MASTER
PLAN FOR CLIMATE RESILIENT
SCHOOL BUILDING THAT A WIDE
FUNDING AND STATE SUPPORT TO
DISTRICT. SIMILAR TO CHAIR
LAYERED COMMENT EARLIER ABOUT
CHILDHOOD FUNDING PROPOSALS FOR
SCHOOL BUSES MULTIPLE STATE
AGENCIES CURRENTLY SUPPORT
DISTRICTS TO SPEND BILLION
ANNUALLY ON BUILDING MAINTAINING
AND OPERATING SCHOOL FACILITIES
WITHOUT A MASTER PLAN FOR CARBON
NEUTRALITY. AND CLIMATE
RESILIENCE. EARLIER THIS MORNING
I SAW A LETTER PROVIDE MORE DE
ON PROPERTY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
KIND. LEADERSHIP AND THE SUPPORT
. THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS. A
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. TOTAL
NUMBER TWENTY THANK TO LINES OF
PLEASE CALL AHEAD. MORNING
CHAIRMAN OF HIS CREAM WITH THE
CHARTER SCHOOLS DEVELOPMENTS
CENTER- WE AS WELL I PLEASED THE
ENTIRE TO PUT UNITS THREE MALE
BUT WILL THAT THE REALLY IS NO
SUCH THING AS A LINE. AND WE
BELIEVE THETO. A FINE UP THE
CAR YIELD RATE IS AND GIVE THEM
LARGE NUMBER OF LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES THAT CURRENTLY ALREADY
HAVE SUBSTANTIAL OPERATING
DEFICIT THAN THEIR MALE
PROGRAMS. AND WE HEAR THAT
EXPANDING THE MANDATE WILL
SIMPLY EXACERBATE THAT PROBLEM
AS SUCH WE THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO BOOST THE MEAL
RATES AND PROVIDE- SOME MINIMUM
FLOORS ESPECIALLY FOR SMALL AND
RURAL DISTRICTS WHERE HI THIS IS
A- ESPECIALLY CHALLENGING. WE
WOULD ALSO SUGGESTED TARGETING
THE START UP ANY QUICK MAKE
GRANTS. TO ALLOW FUNDING FOR
THOSE SCHOOLS THAT CURRENTLY DO
NOT PARTICIPATE IN THE MIDDLE
FEDERAL MEAL PROGRAMS UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL BOTH SCHOOLS
WOULD BE EXCLUDED FROM THESE
CRAMPS WHEN THEY ARE THE ONES
WHO NEED IT THE MOST. FINALLY
I'LL SUPPORT NOTE OUR SUPPORT
FOR THE EXPANSION THE FUNDING
FOR THE CHARTER FACILITY GRANT
PROGRAM THE PROGRAM HAS A LARGE
AND GROWING FUNDING DEFICIT THE
PROPOSAL WELL BACKFILL SOME OF
THAT DEFICIT WE BELIEVE THAT
SOME ADDITIONAL FUNDING IS
NEEDED TO BRING IT UP. TO A
FULLY FUNDED PROGRAM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR MUCH A MODERATOR
NEXT. TRICKLING TWO RELATED LOOK
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS JENNY THALBERG AND I'M A
PRINCIPAL AT UNITY MIDDLE
COLLEGE HIGH SCHOOL A SMALL
CHARTER SCHOOL LOCATED IN ORANGE
I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
INCREASE FUNDING FOR THE SB
SEVEN FORTY CHARTER SCHOOL.
FACILITY GRANT PROGRAM. SB SEVEN
FORTY PROGRAM IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT FOR OUR SCHOOL AND OUR
STUDENTS. WE PROVIDE AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE UNDERSERVED
STUDENTS CAN EXCEL SOCIAL
EMOTIONALLY AND ACADEMICALLY
WITH ALMOST 41% OF OUR
POPULATION DUAL ENROLLED IN
COLLEGE COURSES. WE OFFER AN
EXCEPTIONAL OPPORTUNITY FOR
THESE YOUNG HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
TO GO ACCOMPLISHED AND
SUCCESSFUL AND ACCESS TO
ADEQUATE FACILITIES CONTINUES TO
BE A PRIMARY CHALLENGE FOR OUR
SCHOOL. RECALL THAT GOVERNOR
NEWSOM HAS PROPOSED AN INCREASE
TO ADDRESS THIS CHRONIC FUNDING
SHORTFALL IN THIS PROGRAM AND WE
HOPE YOU WILL SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A MODERATOR
NEXT CALL. OVERLAIN NUMBER
TWENTY NINE IN LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MORNING
THIS IS SERRA WILLIS IN THE
SECOND DIRECTOR FOR TEACHING OF
CALIFORNIA THEY'RE SO SWEET ARE
COMING FROM ITEM THREE WITH
THOSE FROM CHILDREN NOW
CALIFORNIA'S TOGETHER AND COPY
WE APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
CONVERSATION YOU HAD ABOUT THE
MULTILINGUAL LIBRARY THIS
MORNING AND THE GOVERNOR'S
INTENT IN ELEVATING THIS ISSUE.
WE THINK WE HOPE AS YOU MOVE
FORWARD OUR TEACHERS ARE VERY
INTERESTED IN PARTICIPATING IN
THE CONVERSATION AND ENSURING
THAT ALL OF OUR STUDENTS
MULTILINGUAL LEARNERS HAVE
ACCESS TO AUTHENTIC CULTURE
RESPONSIBLE AND LEGAL WRANGLING
RESPONSIVE- TEXT. INCLUDING
NONFICTION AND FICTION- WE ALSO
WANT TO CALL OUT- THE NEED OF
FOCUSING ON ALL THE MULTILINGUAL
LEARNERS IT COULD INCLUDING
MAKING SURE THEIR RESOURCES
AVAILABLE FOR THE BILL LANGUAGE
PROGRAM AND ONE OF THE AND ALSO
SUPPORT THAT ALEJO'S
RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT FOCUSING
ON THE NEED FOR MORE TO A
LANGUAGE. EDUCATORS FOCUSING ON
DEVELOPING AND SUPPORTING. THE
KURDS. ALL OF OUR CURRENT AND-
IN MEETING MANY FOR MULTI
LEARNERS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MUCH- MONTEREY NEXT CALLER.
TOTALING THIRTY GOING TO LOOK
INTO GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS
KARLOS PRO OFFICER
SUPERINTENDENT OF GOVERNMENTAL
AFFAIRS REPRESENTING THE KERN
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS
OFFICE AND THE FORTY SIX SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN KERN COUNTY. IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN A REPORT
RELEASED BY THE L. A. L.
INDICATED DISTRICTS HOME TO
SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION FUNDING
LEVELS HAVE BEEN LOCKED IN AT
THE AMOUNT YOU RECEIVE IN THE
EARLY NINETEEN EIGHTIES. SOME
DISTRICTS NOW RECEIVE LESS THAN
TEN CENTS ON THE DOLLAR WHILE
OTHERS RECEIVE FULL
REIMBURSEMENT FOR THE
TRANSPORTATION COSTS. LCF WAS
ROOTED IN A COMMITMENT TO
FUNDING EQUITY THE FUNDING
INEQUITIES I MENTIONED CREATING
UNEQUAL BURDEN IMPACTING MANY
DISTRICTS MOST NOTABLY THE
UNEQUAL FISCAL BURDEN DILUTES
THE VERY DOLLARS THAT ARE
INTENDED TO SUPPORT THE MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENT POPULATIONS
ENGLISH LEARNERS FOSTER YOUTH
AND STUDENTS POVERTY. WELL WE
FULLY SUPPORT ENVIRONMENTALLY
SAFE BUSES WE STRONGLY ENCOURAGE
LEGISLATURE PRIORITIZED FUNDING
TRANSPORTATION EQUALIZATION
TARGETS CREATING A LEVEL PLAYING
FIELD FOR ALL STUDENTS AND
ELEAZAR THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT THIS
MORNING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR COMMENTS. THE MODERATOR
NEXT CALL. BERTALANFFY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO. I AM
THIRTY TWO PLEASE MAKE SURE YOUR
PHONE IS NOT MUTED YOU LINE IS
NOW OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING. THIS
IS ANDREA BALL ON THE HALF OF
THE CENTRAL VALLEY EDUCATION
COALITION SPEAKING ON SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES FOR THE
SENATE AT CENTRAL VALLEY
EDUCATION COALITION OVER HUNDRED
ELLIE AGE THEY'RE GOING FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE IN SIX
COUNTIES OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE GOOD
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOME TO
SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION THIS IS IN
A CRITICAL ISSUE FOR THE
DISTRICTS IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
WHERE SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION IS.
OFTEN THE ONLY NEED FOR STUDENTS
TO GET TO AND FROM SCHOOL THREE
TWO LONG- ROADS AND TERRAIN. WE
ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU. FOR THE
OPPOSING WORKGROUP AND HOPE YOU
WILL ADOPT THIS TO ADDRESS THE
INCOME. PROCESS HER LICENSING
WILL BACKTRACK. THE CENTRAL
VALLEY ACADEMY CHIU SHORTAGE
ABOUT DRIVER. AND ONE OF THE
THINGS POINTED OUT IN THIS
REGIONAL COALITION IS THE
INCONSISTENT PRACTICES IN THE
PAST PRACTICES FOR LIFE IS BEING
PULLED AFTER RIDERS. THIRTY
STREAMLINE THAT SIMPLIFY IT AND
MAKING IT CONSISTENT WOULD
REALLY GO A LONG WAY TO WE THINK
HE'S GETTING MORE PEOPLE
QUALIFIED TO DRIVE IT CRITICALLY
NEEDED. COLLECTED THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS. MODERATOR NEXT CALLER
. OVERLAIN SIX OLD OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING NUMBER
AND THEY HAVE AND WITH LIGHTNING
WRITING ON THE OF THAT AND CAL
AND ISSUE NUMBER TWO ON METER.
FIRST OFF WE DO WANT TO THANK
WORK THAT THIS COMMITTEE DID A
LOT YEAR AND PARTY ANTI CARRYING
. UNIVERSAL FOR ALL STUDENT NEXT
SEMESTER WITH THE THIS YEAR'S
CREDIT ON BASS IN A SPOKE BY FOR
SCHOOL NUTRITION INCLUDING FULLY
FUNDING NOT ALL WHAT ALSO
PROVIDING PROVIDE THE FULL
AMOUNT OF AND GOVERNOR PROPOSED
FOR SCOLDED STAFF. TRAIN AND
EQUIP WHICH WILL INSURE OPERATE
HELPING OAK PARK IN ORDER TO GET
PLEASE GIVE THE VITAMIN AT
EVENTS. DEPORTED AFTER BUT IN
GOVERNOR. ONCE AND WE COLLECT
MONEY. AND WE CAN ONLY LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU AND
ENSURE THAT THE- UNDER. SCHOOL
WOULD EVER PROGRAM. AT PROPER
STAFFING TRAINING WE THOUGHT
THAT EQUIPMENT STIR MORE
NUTRITIOUS HEALTH. IT INSTALLER
CAL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR- OF MODERATOR CALL. THE LANCASTER FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN GO AHEAD. ONE THIRTY
FIVE ELAINE OPEN TO THANKS YOUR
PHONE IS NOT. HOLBEIN'S THIS IS
B. AND B. WITH THE- SCHOOL AND
COLD. OF THAT YOU NUMBER MOST
SCHOOL. A SCHOOL TO FILL PROBE-
SCHOOL AND COAL. US OF THE COAL
FOR SCHOOL HOUSING TO REQUEST
FOR A ONE TIME NON PROP NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND APPORTIONMENT
OF EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS. FOR
NEW CONSTRUCTION MODERNIZATION
AND TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN.
ALL WE WOULD LIKE TO KNOW THAT
THIS AMOUNT DOES NOT INCLUDE THE
INCREASED COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
MANY OF THE NEW BUILDING CODES-
THAT INCREASE COSTS FOR SCHOOL
FACILITIES AND MAINTENANCE OF
EXAMPLES OR- OF. THE NEW SOLAR
AND ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
ALL REQUIREMENTS SO WE JUST DO
WANT TO KNOW THAT- THE USE OF
THIS PROPOSAL DOES NOT- ABSORB.
THESE COSTS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR KIND
MODERATOR NECKS CALL. THANKS FOR
ALIGNMENT TWENTY FOUR IS OPEN GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING JERRY MEMBER
DELAY FRENCH FOR A TO ON BEHALF
THE SCHOOL FOR ALL COLLEGE IN
ALL OF CASH TAYLOR. FOR A LETTER
AND TOM CAT RANCH. THANK YOU
YOUR LEADERSHIP HAPPINESS
COLONIAL FROM LAST YEAR IN YOUR
CONVERSATION TODAY ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES. A REMINDER THAT PRE
PANDEMIC THE INCOME ELIGIBILITY
TO QUALIFY FOR FREE MEALS FOR A
FAMILY OF FOUR IN CALIFORNIA
WITH THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR FOR REDUCED PRICE
MEALS THE ELIGIBILITY THRESHOLD
WITH FORTY EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR A FAMILY OF FOUR.
AND YOU CAN SEE BEFORE SCHOOL
MEALS FOR ALL FAMILIES ELIGIBLE
FOR RECEIVING FREE MEALS HAD TO
BE IN POVERTY TO QUALIFY WITH
MANY STILL LIVING IN POVERTY.
AND NOT EVEN RECEIVING REDUCED
PRICE MEALS I CAN ASSURE YOU
THAT IS NOT JUST A SLOGAN IT
AFFECTS THE LIVES TO THOUSANDS
OF LOW INCOME FAMILIES. WE
SUPPORT THIS YEAR'S CRITICAL
INVESTMENT IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET PERSONALLY
CHRISTIAN INCLUDING FULLY
FUNDING FOR MEALS FOR ALL AND
THE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
STRENGTHEN THE CONNECTS
CONNECTION BETWEEN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND FARMERS. BY
PROVIDING SCHOOL NUTRITION STAFF
THE TRAINING EQUIPMENT THEY NEED
TO PROVIDE DETAILS WE URGE YOU
TO PLEASE KEEP THIS ITEM OPEN TO
COLLECT MORE DATA AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU TO
ENSURE THAT THE HISTORICALLY
UNDERFUNDED SCHOOL FOOD SERVICE
PROGRAMS. HAVE PROPER RESOURCES
AND STAFFING TO SERVE OUR HUNGRY
CHILDREN THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND BEFORE
WE GO TO THE NEXT CALLER
MODERATOR LET ME ASK HOW MANY
CALLERS. ARE THERE. IN Q. IT
WILL LEFT. HER FOR I MUST'VE
PRESS. SO LET'S TAKE OUR LAST
CALL WELCOME TO THE CA.
BURLINGTON SEVEN ALIGNMENTS
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH HI. R. G.
CHECK ON THE HOUSE BECOME BILL
IN THE IS. WE WANTED TO-
REGISTER IN SUPPORT OF THE
JANUARY BUDGET THAT AUTHORIZES
THE ONE POINT FOUR BILLION AND
THE REMAINING PROP FIFTY ONE
EIGHTY TWELVE GOLD BOND FUND
TWO POINT
IN ONE TIME GENERAL FUND MONEY
FOR SCHOOL FACILITIES. HOWEVER
WE'RE HOPING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE COULD INCREASE THAT
AMOUNT GIVEN NOT- THE SCHOOL
FUNDING FACILITIES NEED FOR THE
STATE IS. MUCH HIGHER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. FOR YOU VERY MUCH
PER. YOUR COMMENTS AND-
MODERATOR. I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND TO OF. FOR DOING A
GREAT JOB WITH EIGHTEEN PEOPLE
UP AND ARE A PUBLIC COMMENT
PERIOD. THEN SO THANK YOU ARE.
THAT CONCLUDES OF OUR BUSINESS
HAVING HEARD FROM. EVERYONE AND
SO LET ME THANK ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY. IF ANY OF
YOU AND I NOTICED AT LEAST ONE
PERSON SAID THEY HAD SUBMITTED A
LETTER OR COMMENT SO SEPARATELY.
IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
TODAY OR YOU FELT LIKE YOUR
COMMENTS WERE LIMITED AND YOU
WANTED TO EXPAND ON YOUR
COMMENTS. WE WOULD WELCOME THAT
SO PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS
OR SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING. TO
THE BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE ONE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE TELL YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT. WE
WANT TO INCLUDE- THAT TESTIMONY
IN THE OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD
SO WE PARTICIPATE- APPRECIATE
YOUR PARTICIPATION. THANKS TO
EVERYBODY FOR THEIR
PARTICIPATION PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION TODAY WE'VE BEEN
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA. OF THE
SENATE AND BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE. ONE WILL STAND
ADJOURNED. JOHN.